Chris and Kuru Kahui were twins, ages three months old when they died in hospital, both suffering from traumatic brain injury. Their death was a result of severe impact, either from direct blows or being hit, thrown or slammed against a hard surface. Violent shaking was another possible cause and couldn't be ruled out. What was clear was that the twins' injuries weren't accidental. Their death was a result of somebody using deliberate force against them. It was determined the injuries were most likely inflicted at the same time by the same person.
克里斯和库鲁·卡胡伊是一对双胞胎，在医院去世时年仅三个月，两人都遭受了创伤性脑损伤。他们的死是由于受到严重撞击，无论是直接击打、被殴打、被扔向或猛撞到硬物表面造成的。剧烈摇晃是另一个可能的原因，也不能被排除。显而易见的是，这对双胞胎的受伤并非意外。他们的死是有人对他们蓄意施暴造成的。经判定，这些伤势极有可能是由同一个人在同一时间造成的。
The twins had been murdered. So who was responsible? Christopher Kahui and Kuru Kahui were born at the National Women's Hospital Auckland, New Zealand on the 20th of March 2006. The twins were later transferred to Middlemore Hospital. Their mother was Maxina King, 29 years old, and their father was Chris Kahui, 21 years old. They had one other child together already, Shane Kahui, who was 13 months of age at the
这对双胞胎遭到了谋杀。那么究竟是谁该负责呢？克里斯托弗·卡胡伊和库鲁·卡胡伊于2006年3月20日在新西兰奥克兰的国家妇女医院出生。这对双胞胎后来被转送到米德尔莫尔医院。他们的母亲是29岁的玛克西娜·金，父亲是21岁的克里斯·卡胡伊。他们当时已经育有一子沙恩·卡胡伊，当时年仅13个月大。
time. Chris and Maxina's relationship was informal and brief, but it had led to the birth of three children in just over a year. Albeit, the twins' birth was unplanned, unexpected and unwanted. Both Chris and Maxina were raised in abusive households, filled with alcohol-filled violence. Maxina's mother left after being badly beaten by Maxina's father one night. She went to hospital and never returned to the house. This left Maxina and her siblings to be raised by her violent, abusive father.
克里斯和玛克西娜的关系非正式且短暂，但在短短一年多里，他们迎来了三个孩子的出生。尽管双胞胎的出生是无计划的、出乎意料的且不被期望的。克里斯和玛克西娜都在充满酒精和暴力的虐待家庭中长大。玛克西娜的母亲在一个晚上遭到玛克西娜的父亲残酷殴打后便离家出走了。她去了医院，再也没有回到那个家。这使得玛克西娜和她的兄弟姐妹们只能由暴力且虐待成性的父亲抚养长大。
Maxina ran away from the home to escape the abuse. She was taken in by a foster family and eventually placed back into her mother's care. Her mother abandoned her for a second time, dropping her off at a relative's house one day and never returning. Maxina was both a victim of and a witness to physical violence as she was growing up, from the people who were supposed to care for her and protect her. Chris Kahui was raised in a very similar household. The adults in his life were alcoholics, more worried about partying and drinking than providing
玛克西娜离家出走以逃避虐待。她被一个寄养家庭收留，最终又回到了母亲身边。她的母亲第二次抛弃了她，有一天把她丢在亲戚家就再也没有回来。玛克西娜在成长过程中既是身体暴力的受害者，也是目击者，而施暴者正是那些本该照顾她、保护她的人。克里斯·卡胡伊也是在一个非常类似的家庭中长大的。他生命中的成年人都是酒鬼，比起为克里斯提供充足的照顾，他们更担心的是聚会和喝酒。
adequate care for Chris. Chris and his siblings could go days without proper food, but the adults rarely went without booze. Chris also copped his fair share of beatings from his parents as he was growing up. It was a rough, tough, abusive and violent upbringing for both of them. The twins Chris and Crew Kahui were born eight weeks prematurely. Despite their premature birth, the twins' condition was actually pretty good. Still, they had to be kept in hospital for monitoring to make sure everything was okay
克里斯和他的兄弟姐妹们可能好几天都吃不上像样的饭，但大人们却很少缺酒。在成长过程中，克里斯也免不了挨父母的痛打。对他们两人来说，这是一个粗暴、艰难、充满虐待和暴力的成长环境。双胞胎克里斯和克鲁·卡胡伊早产了八周。尽管早产，双胞胎的状况其实相当不错。不过，为了确保一切正常，他们必须留在医院接受观察，
before being discharged. They were kept in hospital for around seven weeks until the 7th of May. The nursing notes kept in the first 30 days after the twins' birth showed that the parents, Maxina and Chris, only visited the hospital 11 of those first 30 days. And many of those visits were only brief. When they did visit, hospital staff would encourage them to engage with the twins, doing things such as changing nappies and assisting with feeding. But according to their notes, Maxina and Chris didn't show a lot of interest.
在出院前得到妥善照料。他们在医院呆了大约七周，直到5月7日。双胞胎出生后前30天的护理记录显示，父母玛克西娜和克里斯在这前30天里只去医院探望了11次。而且其中很多次探望都非常短暂。当他们探望时，医院工作人员会鼓励他们与双胞胎互动，比如换尿布和协助喂奶。但根据记录，玛克西娜和克里斯并没有表现出太大的兴趣。
Hospital staff were concerned by this and they eventually reported these concerns. On the 4th of May, a social worker visited Maxina at the hospital. Maxina gave her reasons for their lack of visits as being they were moving house and were trying to care for Shane, so they had little time. Plus, they didn't have a family car. She said she knew the twins had the best possible care in the hospital, so she wasn't overly concerned. After this visit, Maxina stayed with the twins for three nights under hospital staff supervision.
医院工作人员对此感到担忧，并最终报告了这些担忧。5月4日，一名社工在医院探望了玛克西娜。玛克西娜解释了他们探望次数少的原因，称他们当时正在搬家，还要照顾沙恩，所以时间很少。此外，他们没有家庭轿车。她说她知道双胞胎在医院得到了最好的照顾，所以她并没有过度担心。这次探望后，玛克西娜在医院工作人员的监督下与双胞胎一起住了三个晚上。
She demonstrated a good ability to deal with nappy changes and feeding. Staff were actually pretty impressed by what they saw, and they allowed the twins to be discharged from hospital on the 7th of May. The twins were taken home to 22 Courtney Crescent Mungeray East. Also living there with Maxina and Chris was their other son Shane, as well as Stuart King, who is Maxina's brother, and his partner, Mona Kahui, who is Chris's sister. They were in a relationship together as well and had a baby daughter who also lived with them.
她表现出了处理换尿布和喂奶的良好能力。工作人员对他们所看到的印象相当深刻，并允许双胞胎在5月7日出院。这对双胞胎被带回了蒙格雷东部考特尼新月街22号的家中。和玛克西娜及克里斯一起住在那里 的还有他们的另一个儿子沙恩，以及玛克西娜的兄弟斯图尔特·金，还有斯图尔特的伴侣、克里斯的妹妹莫娜·卡胡伊。他们也恋爱了，并育有一个女婴，也和他们住在一起。
So, the four adults and four children all lived together in a three bedroom house. At least seven follow-up visits were conducted by healthcare staff upon the twins' discharge from hospital. The reports from those visits were all positive. The twins were flourishing, and it was obvious they were being well cared for. They were well fed, putting on natural healthy weight, and were all around looking very well. Maxina was seen to interact well with the twins, constantly picking them up, cuddling and kissing them, etc.
因此，四个成年人和四个孩子一起住在一个三居室的房子里。双胞胎出院后，医护人员对他们进行了至少七次随访。这些随访的报告都是积极的。双胞胎发育良好，很明显得到了很好的照顾。他们营养充足，体重自然健康地增长，整体看起来非常健康。据观察，玛克西娜与双胞胎互动良好，不断地抱起他们、拥抱和亲吻他们等。
Both parents were open during the visits and were not evasive at all. The initial concerns about their lack of interest at the hospital were erased. There was no reason for concern or for suspicion. On the 18th of May, 2006, Chris Kahui's mother was admitted to hospital. She was placed in intensive care, suffering pneumonia. Chris Kahui was very concerned about his mother's health and spent considerable time with her in the hospital, often staying overnight. At 1pm on Saturday, June 11th, 2006, Maxina and Chris had a disagreement, resulting in
双方父母在探访期间都很坦诚，一点也没有闪烁其词。最初对他们在医院缺乏兴趣的担忧已经烟消云散。没有任何值得担忧或怀疑的理由。2006年5月18日，克里斯·卡胡伊的母亲被送进医院。她被送进重症监护室，患有肺炎。克里斯·卡胡伊非常担心母亲的健康，在医院陪了她很长时间，经常彻夜不归。2006年6月11日星期六下午1点，玛克西娜和克里斯发生了一场争执，导致
Maxina saying she needed time out. She took their son's shame with her and left the house, leaving Chris to care for the twins. Chris wasn't happy and told Maxina to stay at home, but she left and went to her sister's house where she spent the afternoon. After leaving her sister's house, she went to Chris's father's house, William Kahui, who was also known as Banjo. She actually fell asleep there. Chris was angry that Maxina hadn't returned home.
玛克西娜说她需要冷静一下。她带着他们的儿子沙恩离开了家，留下克里斯照顾双胞胎。克里斯很不高兴，叫玛克西娜呆在家，但她还是离开了，去了她姐姐家，在那里度过了整个下午。离开姐姐家后，她去了克里斯的父亲威廉·卡胡伊的家，威廉也被称为班jo。她其实在那里睡着了。克里斯对玛克西娜没有回家感到很生气。
But later that night, Chris went out looking for her and found her at his father's house. He told her to get up and get her ass home. He said he was stressed and tired and struggling to make the twins bottles and feed them on his own. He said he needed Maxina's help. Maxina refused to return home. She told him to get his ass home so he could look after the twins, who at this time were being cared for by Mona and Stuart.
但那天晚些时候，克里斯出去找她，在她父亲的家里找到了她。他叫她起来，赶紧滚回家。他说他压力很大，很累，很难独自给双胞胎冲奶粉和喂奶。他说他需要玛克西娜的帮忙。玛克西娜拒绝回家。她叫克里斯滚回家去照顾双胞胎，当时双胞胎正由莫娜和斯图尔特照顾。
Maxina refused to return home and Chris had little choice but to leave without her. Maxina ended up taking Shane to hospital that night as she was concerned about her illness he had. He was checked out by a doctor and there was no major concerns. They were able to leave a few hours later. Maxina didn't return home to 22 Courtney Crescent until about 10.30am on Sunday the 12th of June, but she wasn't home for long. About midday Maxina said she was leaving again and going to spend the night with her sister.
玛克西娜拒绝回家，克里斯别无选择，只能独自离开。那天晚上，玛克西娜最终带着沙恩去了医院，因为她担心沙恩的病情。他接受了医生的检查，并没有大碍。几个小时后他们就离开了。直到6月12日星期日上午10点半左右，玛克西娜才回到考特尼新月街22号的家，但她在家待的时间不长。中午左右，玛克西娜说她又要离开，去姐姐家过夜。
Chris didn't want her to go, accusing her that she was going there to party and to get drunk. An argument followed and Maxina told Chris to go and get fucked before walking out. This time she didn't take Shane, so Chris was looking after all three kids. The evidence suggests that the twins were healthy and normal when Maxina left the house. Shortly after Maxina left, Chris's father, Bianja Cahui and Chris's cousin April Saunders and her husband Shane Saunders visited. April Saunders said that when she arrived both twins were in their cots.
克里斯不想让她走，指责她是去那里聚会和喝酒的。随后爆发了一场争执，玛克西娜叫克里斯滚蛋，然后摔门而出。这次她没有带沙恩，所以克里斯得照顾三个孩子。证据表明，玛克西娜离开家时，双胞胎很健康也很正常。玛克西娜离开后不久，克里斯的父亲比亚尼亚·卡胡伊、克里斯的表妹阿普丽尔·桑德斯和她的丈夫沙恩·桑德斯来访。阿普丽尔·桑德斯说，她到达时，双胞胎都在婴儿床里。
You could hear one of them was awake. She went in to check on them and saw that Crue was the one awake. Crue was making a hungry cry and there was a half finished bottle next to his cot. Chris mentioned that he had been feeding Crue and he most likely wanted to finish the bottle. April picked Crue up and fed him. She said everything was normal. He took the bottle normally, he looked well, he looked healthy, there were no injuries on him at all.
你能听到其中一个醒着。她进去查看，发现醒着的是克鲁。克鲁发出饥饿的哭声，他的婴儿床旁有一个喝了一半的奶瓶。克里斯提到他一直在喂克鲁，克鲁很可能是想喝完剩下的奶。阿普丽尔抱起克鲁喂他。她说一切都很正常。他很正常地喝了奶，看起来很好，很健康，身上一点伤也没有。
She finished the bottle and went straight back to sleep. Baby Chris remained asleep, having already been fed. April and Shane Saunders left about 2pm and when they left there were no problems at all. About 7pm that night, Chris dropped his sister Mona and her baby daughter off at the hospital to visit their mum. He says he was gone for about 20 minutes. Stuart King was at home mourning the kids and he says Chris was gone for about 10 or 15 minutes.
他喝完奶，直接又睡着了。婴儿克里斯由于已经吃过奶，一直在睡觉。阿普丽尔和沙恩·桑德斯于下午2点左右离开，他们离开时一切正常。那天晚上7点左右，克里斯开车载着妹妹莫娜和她的女婴去医院探望他们的母亲。他说他离开了大约20分钟。斯图尔特·金当时在家照顾孩子，他说克里斯离开大约10或15分钟。
About 8.25pm Mona returned home with her daughter and father Banjo Kahui. Mona's intentions were to drop off her baby daughter and return to the hospital to spend the night with her mum. Almost immediately there was an argument between Banjo and Chris. Banjo had a go at him about Maxina and asked why she wasn't there. Chris told him to shut up, it wasn't his relationship. Mona got involved as well. It turned into a bit of a heated argument that got Chris worked up.
晚上8点25分左右，莫娜和女儿以及父亲班卓·卡胡伊回到了家。莫娜的本意是放下女婴，然后返回医院陪母亲过夜。几乎立刻，班卓和克里斯之间就发生了争执。班卓因为玛克西娜的事数落了克里斯一顿，质问她为什么不在。克里斯叫他闭嘴，这又不是他的恋爱关系。莫娜也参与了进来。这演变成了一场激烈的争论，让克里斯情绪激动起来。
About 8.40pm they all went outside for a smoke. Chris was angry that he couldn't go with Mona back to the hospital to see their mum because he had to stay at home and look after the kids. He was also still agitated over the argument he had just had. After the smoke Chris walked back inside. He went into the twins bedroom. He was alone in their room for a period of time. Just how long this period of time is depends on who was telling the story.
晚上8点40分左右，他们都走到外面抽烟。克里斯很生气，因为他不能和莫娜一起回医院去看妈妈，而必须留在家里照顾孩子。他对手刚刚经历的争论也依然感到烦躁。抽完烟后，克里斯走回屋内。他走进了双胞胎的卧室。他在他们的房间里独自待了一段时间。至于这段时间究竟有多长，这取决于谁在讲述这个故事。
Mona says it was 10 minutes that Chris was alone in the room. Chris agreed with that at one point but later changed his story and said it was more like 3 minutes. But regardless the evidence is clear he was in the room by himself for at least 3 minutes possibly longer. The next part of the story is also unclear and we will probably never know exactly what happened. Again it depends on whose story you listen to but even then Chris has changed his story
莫娜说克里斯独自在房间里待了10分钟。克里斯一度同意这种说法，但后来改变了说法，说大概是3分钟左右。但无论如何，证据很明显，他独自在房间里至少待了3分钟，甚至可能更久。故事的下一部分也不太清楚，我们可能永远不会确切知道发生了什么。同样，这取决于你听谁的故事，但即便如此，克里斯已经
multiple times already. But what is clear is that at some point Mona walked into the room with Chris and the twins. She says she picked up crew to give him a cuddle before she left to go back to the hospital. She said Chris's face was pale, his lips were purple and his eyes were rolling back in his head. Chris didn't appear too worried. He said he gets like that when he is tired. But Mona realised crew wasn't breathing.
多次改变了他的说法。但很明显的是，在某个时刻，莫娜和克里斯以及双胞胎一起走进了房间。她说她抱起克鲁想在回医院前抱抱他。她说克里斯的脸色苍白，嘴唇发紫，双眼往上翻。克里斯看起来并不太担心。他说他累了的时候就会这样。但莫娜意识到克鲁没有呼吸了。
She ran to get her partner Stuart. Stuart ran into the room until cold of crew. He says the crew's lips were dark purple and they were getting darker and darker. He also says his body was flimsy and limp. He said crew wasn't breathing for what seemed like 5 to 10 minutes. He was just lifeless. Then suddenly crew started to breathe in short bursts like he was trying to suck in the air. He was making a queasy sound.
她跑去找伴侣斯图尔特。斯图尔特跑进房间，抱住克鲁。他说克鲁的嘴唇是深紫色的，而且颜色越来越深。他还说克鲁的身体软绵绵的。他说克鲁有五到十分钟没有呼吸。他简直毫无生气。然后突然间，克鲁开始短促地喘气，就像在拼命吸气一样。他发出令人反胃的声音。
Every time he opened his eyes they would roll back and his hands were shaking. Stuart thought crew was dead at one stage. It was a very serious incident. Again depending on who is telling the story and what version of the story they are telling, crew may have been given CPR by Chris. Well Chris may have gone to attempt CPR but crew started breathing before he had to perform. Either way crew started to breathe again and in Chris's words he had come good. Still given the serious nature of what had occurred you would think seeking medical attention
每次他睁开眼睛，眼睛就会往上翻，双手也在颤抖。斯图尔特一度以为克鲁死了。这是一起非常严重的事件。同样，取决于谁在讲述这个故事以及他们讲述的是哪个版本，克里斯可能对克鲁实施了心肺复苏术。或者克里斯可能正准备尝试心肺复苏，但克鲁在他实施之前就开始呼吸了。无论如何，克鲁重新开始呼吸，用克里斯的话说，他已经恢复好了。尽管发生了如此严重的事件，你本会认为寻求医疗救助
would be the next step. But it wasn't. They didn't take crew to hospital and they didn't call an ambulance. B&J, Mona and Stuart were all of the opinion crew should be checked out. But Chris didn't want medical help. He said nah he's breathing again. He should be fine now. He refused to take them to hospital and refused an ambulance.
将是下一步行动。但事实并非如此。他们没有把克鲁送到医院，也没有叫救护车。班卓、莫娜和斯图尔特都认为应该让克鲁接受检查。但克里斯不想要医疗救助。他说，不用了，他又在呼吸了。他现在应该没事了。他拒绝带他们去医院，也拒绝叫救护车。
Instead he instructed B&J and Mona to go out and look for Maxina. He just wanted her home. B&J and Mona did what Chris asked. They left the house to try and find Maxina but they couldn't find her. B&J dropped Mona at the hospital so she could be with her mum and then he returned to 22 Courtney Crescent. He looked after Shane while Chris slept the night in the twins room to make sure they kept breathing.
相反，他指示班卓和莫娜出去找玛克西娜。他只是想让她回家。班卓和莫娜照着克里斯的要求做了。他们离开家去寻找玛克西娜，但没能找到她。班卓把莫娜送到医院陪伴母亲，然后返回考特尼新月街22号。他照顾沙恩，而克里斯则在双胞胎的房间里睡了一夜，以确保他们一直在呼吸。
So by doing that Chris did show he had concerns. The next morning Tuesday the 13th of June 2006 Chris woke up and checked on the twins. He noticed a bruise on baby Chris's face. He left home about 9am. The twins and Shane stayed at home with Stuart. Maxina arrived home about 9.35am. Chris was still out. She spoke to Stuart who told her about the incident the night before with crew.
通过这样做，克里斯确实表现出了他的担忧。第二天早上，即2006年6月13日星期二，克里斯醒来查看双胞胎的情况。他注意到婴儿克里斯的脸上有一处淤青。他在早上9点左右离开家。双胞胎和沙恩留在家里和斯图尔特在一起。玛克西娜于上午9点35分左右回到家。克里斯还在外面。她和斯图尔特交谈，斯图尔特告诉她前一天晚上克鲁发生的事故。
But she says he didn't express exactly how serious it was. Maxina went to the twins room to check on them. Both were asleep and both were breathing. Chris arrived home shortly after. She confronted him and said, what the fuck was happening while I was gone away? How the hell did our boy get that new bruise on his face? What the hell happened? Chris' response to her was that he left the door of the twins room open and Shane had
但她说斯图尔特并没有明确表达事情有多严重。玛克西娜去双胞胎房间查看情况。两个都在睡觉，也都还在呼吸。克里斯不久后回到家。她质问他并说道：“我不在的时候到底发生了什么事？我们的小男孩脸上怎么会无缘无故多了一块淤青？到底发生了什么？”克里斯对她的回应是，他把双胞胎房间的门开着，沙恩
crawled in the room and some of them got to the twins causing the bruise. Maxina started yelling at Chris and his response was that Maxina should have been at home taking care of the kids. Now remember Maxina said to Chris how the hell did our boy get that new bruise on his face? That's because there had recently been another bruise on his face and when she confronted Chris about that first bruise a few days earlier, he gave the exact same story he had just given to the fresh bruise.
爬进了房间，弄到了双胞胎身上才导致了淤青。玛克西娜开始对克里斯大喊大叫，而克里斯的回应是玛克西娜本该在家照顾孩子。现在大家想想，玛克西娜对克里斯说我们的小男孩脸上怎么会有新淤青？那是因为不久前他的脸上刚刚有过另一块淤青，当几天前她就第一块淤青质问克里斯时，他给出的说辞和刚刚对新淤青给出的说辞完全一样。
That he left the door open and Shane crawled in and caused it. Maxina says that she saw two full bottles ready to go. But Chris told her the twins weren't hungry and didn't want their feed. She thought the twins were just asleep. Without looking back, she realises they were most likely unconscious. Maxina says she didn't immediately realise how serious their condition was or how badly they had been hurt. The incident with crew the night before wasn't properly explained to her.
那就是他把门开着，沙恩爬进来弄伤的。玛克西娜说她看到了两瓶准备好的冲好奶。但克里斯告诉她，双胞胎不饿，不想吃奶。她以为双胞胎只是在睡觉。回想起来，她意识到他们当时很可能已经失去知觉了。玛克西娜说她当时并没有立刻意识到他们的病情有多严重，或者他们受了多重的伤。前一天晚上克鲁发生的事故并没有向她做恰当的解释。
She was of the opinion that crew momentarily stopped breathing then started breathing straight away. She says there was no mention to her of him turning purple or CPR or not breathing for several minutes. And definitely no mention from anyone that they thought crew was dead at one point. Maxina suggested taking the twins to their GP, Dr. Naya, to get checked out. Chris agreed and they got in the car to head to Dr. Naya's. But first they stopped at McDonald's for lunch.
她当时以为克鲁只是短暂停止呼吸，然后马上又恢复了呼吸。她说没人向她提及克鲁脸色变紫、做心肺复苏或停止呼吸好几分钟的事。更绝对没有人向她提过当时有人以为克鲁已经死了。玛克西娜建议带双胞胎去看全科医生娜亚医生检查一下。克里斯同意了，他们上车前往娜亚医生那里。但他们先在麦当劳停下来吃午饭。
Again, keep in mind Maxina says she didn't realise how serious the situation was at this point. And Chris wasn't exactly forthcoming with information to her. They arrived at the doctors about 1pm. Chris described the incident the night before where crew stopped breathing. But he failed to mention that neither twin had been fed or was waiting for food since that time. Straight away Dr. Naya could see the twins were neurologically unwell.
再次提醒大家，玛克西娜说她当时并没有意识到情况有多严重。而且克里斯对她也并非知无不言。他们在下午1点左右到达诊所。克里斯描述了前一天晚上克鲁停止呼吸的事件。但他隐瞒了双胞胎自那以后一直没有喂食、也没有等食物的事实。娜亚医生一眼就看出这对双胞胎的神经系统状况不佳。
He actually asked Chris and Maxina if the babies had been dropped on their heads. He immediately telephoned in a referral to Middlemore Hospital. He told Chris and Maxina that the twins had to be taken to the hospital straight away. Dr. Naya says that Chris and Maxina seemed to understand his instruction and the serious nature of the twins condition. They were very sick and needed to be seen at the hospital immediately. So Chris and Maxina jumped in their car with the twins. But Chris decided he didn't want to go to hospital.
他甚至问克里斯和玛克西娜，婴儿是不是头部着地摔过。他立即打电话给米德尔莫尔医院进行转诊。他告诉克里斯和玛克西娜，必须马上把双胞胎送往医院。娜亚医生说，克里斯和玛克西娜似乎听懂了他的指示，也明白了双胞胎病情的严重性。他们病得很重，需要立刻去医院看病。于是克里斯和玛克西娜带着双胞胎跳上车。但克里斯决定不想去医院。
He drove straight past the turn off. For some reason Maxina asked him to stop at the shop so she could buy nappies and other baby supplies. He stopped and she got what she needed. They returned home sometime before 2pm. When they got home Chris was amped up, agitated and angry. Maxina was swearing and yelling at him saying that he needed to go to hospital with her. But Chris didn't want to go to hospital.
他直接把车开过了路口。不知为什么，玛克西娜叫他在商店停一下，以便她买尿布和其他婴儿用品。他停下车，她买好了需要的东西。他们在下午2点前某个时间回到了家。到家后，克里斯情绪高涨、烦躁且愤怒。玛克西娜对大喊大叫并骂脏话，说他必须跟她一起去医院。但克里斯不想去医院。
He decided it was all too much and he left the house to go for a walk. Here is Maxina's account of what happened. Like I said when we drove back from the doctors, he didn't want to go to the hospital. I stopped at a countdown. We got back to Courtney Krez and I said wait here with the car with the twins. I went back inside the house and came back out and he was gone and I was pissed off. I started running around and getting things and I rang his sister Tracy and I said to her Tracy I need your help she goes what's the matter and I went I need you to ring
他觉得一切都无法承受，于是离家出走去散步。以下是玛克西娜对当时情况的描述。就像我说的，当我们从医生那里开车回来时，他不想去医院。我在倒计时商店停了一下。我们回到考特尼新月街，我说你带着车和双胞胎在这里等一下。我走回屋里，又走出来时他已经不见了，我气炸了。我开始到处跑着拿东西，我给他的妹妹特雷西打电话，我对她说，特雷西我需要你的帮忙，她说怎么了，我说我需要你给
Chris and get his ass back here and she goes well what do you want me to make up to? What am I going to do and I went I just I lost it and I went you can you know how you're always bossing around you can get on the phone and tell him to get his ass back here and help me to get the boys to the hospital and I started crying on the phone and she goes what the fuck is happening and I went I don't know Tracy we just asked the doctors he said get to the hospital and she goes why don't you go to the hospital and I went because I wanted to well because Chris didn't want to come and because I wanted to grab the other stuff she goes well you should have just not bothered and just who cares what he wanted
克里斯打电话让他滚回来，她说好吧，那我该编什么借口？我要做什么，我当时情绪崩溃了，我说你可以，你知道你平时不是总爱发号施令吗，你可以打电话叫他滚回来，帮我把男孩们送去医院，我在电话里哭了起来，她说到底发生了什么事，我说我不知道特雷西，我们刚问了医生，他说去医院，她说你为什么不去医院，我说因为我想去，好吧，因为克里斯不想去，也因为我想顺便拿其他东西，她说好吧，你本可以不用管，谁管他想要什么
you should have just yeah pretty hard to make that the driver what am I going to do turn the wheel for him he drove from the top this and she she was like oh please man if you could ever help me this is how you can help me now ring your brother and make sure you get it done I'm not gonna go through all of this on my own he helped me now you help me these are our kids and you're part of it so you do something so hang up on her and she did she did try and get a hold of Chris but I heard that she actually drove over and went to go and find him she arrived at the house um took the shirt and he said yeah now Chris just pissed off met said that she had to go to the to the hospital because her and Chris went to
你本应该，唉，要让司机听话太难了，我能怎么办，替他转方向盘吗，他从上面开车，她当时就像，求求你了玛姆，如果你能帮我一次，现在就是你帮我的时候了，给你弟弟打电话，确保他回来，我可不想一个人面对这一切，他以前帮过我，现在你帮我，这些是我们的孩子，你也是其中一分子，所以你想想办法，于是我挂断了她的电话，她确实试着联系克里斯，但我听说她其实开车过去找他了，她到达房子里嗯拿了衬衫，他说好吧，现在克里斯气冲冲的，说她必须去医院，因为她和克里斯去了
the doctors but then Chris took off and left the baby so she explained it to Tracy and Tracy went off and looked for Chris Maxina did take the twins up at the hospital without Chris arriving there about 2 37 p.m when tree arched the bruise on baby Chris's face was noticed and Maxina could only give the story that she had been told that their other son Shane had caused it the twins were given category three status the most serious is category one so despite having a phone referral from a doctor saying the twins were suffering neurological damage the hospital still only gave category three status which is usually around a 30 minute wait the twins were eventually seen by another nurse who noted fresh bruising on both twins faces it was also discovered
医生那里，但随后克里斯跑了，把婴儿留下了，于是她向特雷西解释了情况，特雷西便去找克里斯。玛克西娜在下午2点37分左右带着双胞胎到达医院，而克里斯当时并没有到场。当到达时，婴儿克里斯脸上的淤青被发现了，玛克西娜只能转述别人告诉她的故事，即他们的另一个儿子沙恩造成的。这对双胞胎被评为三级状态，最严重的是一级。因此，尽管有医生的电话转诊信说明这对双胞胎正在遭受神经系统损伤，医院仍然只给予了三级状态，这通常需要大约30分钟的等待时间。这对双胞胎最终被另一名护士接诊，护士注意到双胞胎脸上都有新鲜的淤青。还发现
that baby Chris had a broken leg and both twins had fractured ribs and they were both suffering traumatic brain injuries Chris and crew eventually started fitting and compulsive about 3 40 p.m Maxina called her brother Stuart's phone by now Chris had returned home from his walk and he and Stuart were playing a game on the Sony PlayStation Maxina asked to speak to Chris Chris took the phone and said whatever and hung up in relation to this call Stuart said well it was his turn on the game so he played again Chris was more interested in the Sony PlayStation than what was happening up at the hospital with these twins Maxina made numerous more telephone calls to Stuart her sister and to Chris's sister
婴儿克里斯有一条断腿，双胞胎的肋骨都有骨折，并且都遭受了创伤性脑损伤。下午3点40分左右，克里斯和克鲁最终开始抽搐和痉挛。玛克西娜拨通了她兄弟斯图尔特的电话。此时克里斯已经散步回来，他和斯图尔特正在索尼PlayStation上玩游戏。玛克西娜要求和克里斯通话，克里斯接起电话说了声随便便挂断了。关于这通电话，斯图尔特说，好吧，当时轮到他玩游戏了，所以他又接着玩了。比起双胞胎在医院里的情况，克里斯显然对索尼PlayStation更感兴趣。玛克西娜又给斯图尔特、她的姐姐以及克里斯的妹妹打了好几个电话，
to try and get someone to get through his head how serious the situation was and to get him up to the hospital but Chris was going nowhere near the hospital by now hospital staff had started making accusations at Maxina it was apparent the injuries to the twins had been done by somebody they accused her of child abuse Maxina started freaking out she freely admits her behavior at the hospital was an ideal but she said she was panicked and didn't know what to do she had no idea what was going on Chris had said Shane got into the room and caused a bruise on the twins face now she was being told about fractured ribs a broken leg brain damage and being accused of child abuse meanwhile Chris was still playing the PlayStation the twins were transferred to
试图让某人让克里斯明白情况有多严重，并把他叫到医院来，但克里斯根本不肯去医院。此时，医院工作人员开始指责玛克西娜。很明显，双胞胎身上的伤是某人造成的，他们指责她虐待儿童。玛克西娜开始惊慌失措，她大方承认自己在医院的行为不够理想，但她说她当时吓坏了，不知道该怎么办。她完全不知道发生了什么事。克里斯之前说过是沙恩闯进房间导致了双胞胎脸上的淤青，现在却有人告诉她肋骨骨折、断腿、脑损伤，并指责她虐待儿童。与此同时，克里斯还在玩PlayStation。这对双胞胎被转运至
Starship Hospital by ambulance shortly after 6 p.m Chris finally made an appearance at the hospital about 10 p.m it was at this time Maxina says she first heard about crew not breathing for minutes his lips turning blue and CPR B&J said he performed CPR Chris said he performed CPR Stuart said he didn't see anyone perform CPR B&J later admitted lying to protect Chris in case something went wrong and that he didn't perform CPR at all their stories were a mess the injuries to the twins were so bad that nothing could be done to save them little crew died at 4.55 a.m on the 18th of June and little Chris died at 6.45 p.m later that same day Chris was shown to have older injuries as well fractured ribs that were in the process of healing
星舰儿童医院的救护车在下午6点过后不久出发。克里斯直到晚上10点左右才终于露面。就在这个时候，玛克西娜说她第一次听说克鲁有几分钟没有呼吸、嘴唇变蓝以及做心肺复苏的事。班卓说他做了心肺复苏，克里斯说他做了心肺复苏，斯图尔特说他没看到任何人做心肺复苏。班卓后来承认撒谎是为了保护克里斯，以防万一出了什么问题，他根本没有做过心肺复苏。他们的谎言乱成一团。双胞胎的伤势如此严重，以至于无力回天。小克鲁于6月18日凌晨4点55分去世，小克里斯于当天晚些时候傍晚6点45分去世。克里斯身上也被发现有较旧的伤势，肋骨骨折正在愈合过程中。
as well as these older fractures he had fresh fractures of the ribs he also had a broken leg his cause of death was traumatic brain injury crew also had older root fractures that were in the process of healing his cause of death traumatic brain injury experts were of the view that the twins brain injuries had been caused by severe impact rapid acceleration and the acceleration of the head either from direct blows or being hit or thrown or slammed against the hard surface it's also possible violent shaking was the cause of death that couldn't be ruled out
除了这些陈旧性骨折外，他还有新鲜的肋骨骨折。他还有一条断腿。他的死因是创伤性脑损伤。克鲁也有正在愈合过程中的陈旧性肋骨骨折。他的死因是创伤性脑损伤。专家认为，这对双胞胎的脑损伤是由严重撞击、头部快速加速和减速造成的，无论是直接击打、被殴打、被扔向或猛撞到硬物表面。剧烈摇晃也有可能是死因，这一点不能被排除。
the prosecution experts were of the view that the injuries must have occurred after their last normal feed there is no way the twins would have been able to feed normally after receiving these injuries so that's where the evidence of April Saunders is important she fed crew shortly after lunchtime on the afternoon of the 12th of June crew took his bottle normally and went back to sleep showing the injuries could not have been there at that time they had to have occurred after April Saunders and her husband left 22 Courtney Crescent which was about 2 p.m that afternoon the effects of the twins injuries would have been immediate and obvious with either an alteration
控方专家认为，这些伤势一定是在他们最后一次正常喂食之后发生的。这对双胞胎在遭受这些伤势后绝对不可能还能正常进食。因此，阿普丽尔·桑德斯的证词至关重要。她在6月12日下午午饭后不久喂了克鲁。克鲁很正常地喝了奶瓶里的奶并重新睡着了，这表明当时伤势不可能已经存在。伤势必定发生在阿普丽尔·桑德斯和她的丈夫离开考特尼新月街22号之后，也就是那天下午2点左右。这对双胞胎受伤后的影响将是直接且明显的，伴随着
to that level of consciousness or a complete loss of consciousness and they would have continued to remain abnormal from that point on their injuries were devastating and extensive a police investigation was already underway before the twins had died they interviewed everyone who had anything to do with the twins many people were interviewed more than once giving multiple statements Chris Cahouie was one of those who was interviewed by police on three separate occasions it was important to learn exactly when the twins last fed normally to try and narrow down the time their injuries occurred
意识水平的改变或意识完全丧失，并且从那时起他们的状态会一直异常。他们的伤势毁灭性且极其广泛。在双胞胎去世前，警方就已经展开了调查。他们盘问了所有与双胞胎有关的人。许多人接受了不止一次的盘问，并做出了多份供述。克里斯·卡胡伊就是三次接受警方盘问的人之一。弄清双胞胎最后一次正常进食的具体时间非常重要，以便缩小他们受伤时间的范围。
Chris Cahouie was interviewed on the 13th of June before the twins had passed away again on the 21st of June three days after their death and then again on the 3rd of October in his three police interviews Chris gave similar versions saying pretty much the same thing he says he definitely fed the twins after April fed crew and therefore after Maxina had already left the house in his first interview he said he fed the twins again around five or six o'clock that night and then again around 11 o'clock he even said that they fed again the next morning around 6 a.m he gave a similar account in his next two interviews so in the three interviews one conducted before and two conducted soon after the twins death Chris said he had last fed the twins
克里斯·卡胡伊于6月13日在双胞胎去世前接受了盘问，6月21日双胞胎去世三天后再次接受盘问，然后又在10月3日接受了盘问。在其三次警方盘问中，克里斯给出了相似的说法，内容大同小异。他说自己在阿普丽尔喂了克鲁之后、也就是在玛克西娜已经离开家之后，绝对给双胞胎喂过奶。他在第一次盘问中说，那天晚上五六点左右他又喂了双胞胎一次，然后大约11点又喂了一次。他甚至说第二天早上6点左右他们又吃了一顿。他在接下来的两次盘问中给出了类似的说法。因此，在这三次盘问中，一次在双胞胎去世前进行，两次在双胞胎去世后不久进行，克里斯都表示他最后一次喂双胞胎是在
the police investigation was exhaustive and lasted four months they concluded only one person could have been responsible for the twins death their father Chris Cahouie was charged with their murder in late October Chris was released on bail whilst the waiting trial he was given strict conditions not to consume alcohol and not to bury young children under 12 years of age as it turns out those conditions were too strict he was arrested for breaching the conditions and was to be kept in jail until his trial that is until the father of the Cahouie twins is one of the first people to take advantage of amendments to the bail act which came into force yesterday Cahouie was sent to
警方的调查旷日持久，持续了四个月。他们得出结论，只有一个人应对双胞胎的死负责。他们的父亲克里斯·卡胡伊于10月下旬被控谋杀。克里斯在等待审判期间被保释，条件极为严格，不得饮用酒精饮料，且不得陪伴12岁以下的儿童。事实证明，这些条件过于严厉。他因违反保释条件而被捕，并将被关押在监狱中直到受审，直到卡胡伊双胞胎的父亲成为第一批利用昨天生效的保释法修正案的人之一。卡胡伊被送往
jail six weeks ago for breaching his bail conditions by drinking beer and being in the presence of children under 12 but the new laws mean that those sorts of breaches will no longer mean a person is automatically taken into custody clear robbie reports family members arrived at court to show their support for Chris Cahouie the 22 year old spent the last 42 days in solitary confinement but new bail laws introduced yesterday mean he won't be there for much longer under the bail amendment act there now has to be not just a risk but a real and substantial risk of the offender absconding interfering with witnesses or reoffending it's aimed at getting prison numbers down Cahouie's risk was deemed moderate you've got to look at the fact that he has no previous
监狱关押了六周，原因是他通过喝啤酒和身处12岁以下儿童身边违反了保释条件。但新法律意味着，此类违规行为将不再意味着此人会被自动拘留。克莱尔·罗比报道称，家庭成员来到法庭对克里斯·卡胡伊表示支持。这名22岁的年轻人过去42天一直在单独监禁中度过，但昨天出台的新保释法意味着他不会在那里待太久了。根据《保释修正案法》，现在不仅需要存在风险，而且需要存在嫌疑人潜逃、干预证人或重新犯罪的实质性且真实的风险。此举旨在降低监狱人数。卡胡伊的风险被认为是中等的。你必须看到这样一个事实，即他没有前科，
offending and certainly nothing of a violent nature but bail came with tough conditions again he's not to drink alcohol or be in the presence of children under 12 without an adult next year he'll be back in court to face charges of killing his twin three month old sons Chris and crew so he breaks the conditions of staying away from children under 12 and drinking alcohol but he was released with the same bail conditions as well as a number of other conditions he was freed until his trial during the police investigation and even after chris had been charged a trial by media had already started singling out mainly one person the twins mother Maxina she wore the brunt of the
当然也没有任何暴力性质的犯罪。但保释附带了严厉的条件。同样，他不得饮酒，也不得在没有成年人陪伴的情况下接近12岁以下的儿童。明年他将重返法庭，面对杀害他三个月大的双胞胎儿子克里斯和克鲁的指控。所以他违反了远离12岁以下儿童和饮酒的保释条件，但他获释时享受了与之前相同的保释条件以及其他一些条件。在审判之前他恢复了自由。在警方调查期间，甚至在克里斯被起诉之后，一场媒体审判就已经开始了，主要矛头直指一个人，那就是双胞胎的母亲玛克西娜。她承受了
media and in turn the public's fury and outrage she was turned into a monster quickly becoming New Zealand's most hated woman now she wasn't an innocent angel by any stretch but the fact she was the one targeted was interesting after all she wasn't the one that had been charged Chris's trial commenced on the 14th of April 2008 and ran for about six weeks Chris's defense team had one main strategy in mind well the lawyer for the man accused of murdering his twin sons is blaming the fatal injuries on the baby's mother 23 year old Chris Kahui is on trial at the High Court in Auckland over the deaths of the three month old twins who died from severe brain damage in June of 2006 yesterday
媒体的狂轰滥炸，进而承受了公众的愤怒和暴怒。她被妖魔化，迅速变成了新西兰最受恨之入骨的女人。现在她绝不是一个清白的天使，但她成为被针对的目标这一事实很有意思。毕竟，被起诉的人并不是她。克里斯的审判于2008年4月14日开始，持续了大约六周。克里斯的辩护团队当时有一个主要策略，那就是为被控谋杀双胞胎儿子的男子进行辩护的律师将致命伤归咎于孩子的母亲。23岁的克里斯·卡胡伊在奥克兰高等法院受审，罪名是2006年6月因严重脑损伤死亡的三个月大双胞胎。昨天
both the Crown and Defense opened their cases joy Reed was there and she joins us now firstly what are the defense saying in this this case joy well they only had a chance to make a very brief opening statement and in that Mr Kahui's lawyer Lorraine Smith told the court that her client didn't kill the twins now she says there's no direct evidence or any one witness proving that Chris Kahui is the killer and she's blaming the deaths on Mr Kahui's ex-girlfriend who's Maxina King who has been described in court as outspoken and verbally abusive the defense cases and let me put it bluntly that most probably the mother Maxina King inflicted the injuries and you will hear that Maxina King told a witness months after Chris Kahui was charged
控辩双方都发表了开案陈词。乔·里德当时在现场，现在她加入了我们的连线。乔，首先辩方在这个案件中是怎么说的？好吧，他们只有机会做一个非常简短的开案陈词。在陈词中，卡胡伊先生的律师洛林·史密斯告诉法庭，她的当事人并没有杀死双胞胎。现在她说，没有任何直接证据或任何单一证人证明克里斯·卡胡伊是凶手，她将死亡归咎于卡胡伊先生的前女友玛克西娜·金，玛克西娜在法庭上被形容为直言不讳和有言语虐待倾向。辩方的案件，请容我直言，最可能是母亲玛克西娜·金造成了这些伤势，你们将听到玛克西娜·金在克里斯·卡胡伊被起诉几个月后对一名证人说
that she did it and Chris didn't now Lorraine Smith is planning to call that witness to the stand but also some internationally respected medical experts one a pathologist and another a pediatrician who she says will tell the court that it's impossible to tell with any accuracy when the twins were injured and that would indicate that the injuries could have been inflicted when Maxina King was in fact at home which miss Smith says effectively contradicts the main medical evidence of the crown so is the crown case as outlined yesterday pretty reliant on the issue of timing in terms of establishing Chris Kahui's guilt yes very very much so in its opening yesterday crown lawyer Simon Morse made it very very clear that Chris Kahui is the only person who can be at fault for his
是她干的，而不是克里斯。洛林·史密斯正计划传唤该证人出庭作证，同时还将传唤一些在国际上备受尊敬的医疗专家，其中包括一名病理学家和一名儿科医生。她说这些专家将告诉法庭，根本无法准确判断双胞胎是在什么时候受伤的，这表明这些伤势可能是在玛克西娜·金实际上在家的时候造成的。史密斯女士称，这有效地反驳了控方的主要医学证据。那么，正如昨天所概述的那样，控方的案件在很大程度上依赖于确定克里斯·卡胡伊有罪的时间节点问题吗？是的，非常非常依赖。在昨天的开案陈词中，控方律师西蒙·莫斯非常明确地表示，克里斯·卡胡伊是唯一一个应对他
baby son's death and that is due to timing now they say that the twins mother Maxina King was not at home when the babies could have been fatally hurt and that Chris Kahui was the only one who had the chance to harm them because he was alone with the twins for about three to ten minutes and immediately after that Chris's sister Mona Kahui noticed that baby crew had in fact stopped breathing and as she stooped to pick this baby up she noticed that his lips had gone purple his eyes were rolling back and he seemed to have stopped breathing this is the first time that there is any evidence that the twins either of the twins had been injured and immediately prior to it used is in the room with them alone now the family never called an ambulance and after
婴儿儿子的死负责的人，这是由时间决定的。现在他们说，双胞胎的母亲玛克西娜·金在婴儿可能遭受致命伤害时并不在家，而克里斯·卡胡伊是唯一有机会伤害他们的人，因为他独自和双胞胎待了大约三到十分钟，紧接着克里斯的妹妹莫娜·卡胡伊注意到婴儿克鲁实际上已经停止呼吸，当她弯腰抱起这个婴儿时，她注意到他的嘴唇变紫了，双眼上翻，并且似乎已经停止呼吸。这是第一次有证据表明双胞胎中的任何一个曾受伤，而在此之前不久，他正独自和他们在房间里。现在，家人从未叫过救护车，而且在
the babies fell asleep they never woke up now and one of Chris Kahui's interviews with police he tried to say that his one-year-old son had in fact injured the babies but the crown also refutes that argument there's no way that the injuries to either twin let alone both could have been caused by accident it's simply impossible so whoever did it did it deliberately now the court heard that the babies suffered from massive brain injuries that they've been grasped so tightly around their chest that their ribs had popped and that they've been slammed against a hard surface the tiny bodies also bore evidence of other abuse but the jury was told that no medical treatment could have saved the babies from dying that clip and all future clips that will be played on this episode
婴儿们入睡后，他们就再也没有醒过来。现在，在克里斯·卡胡伊接受警方的一次盘问中，他曾试图说他一岁大的儿子实际上伤害了婴儿，但控方也驳斥了这种说法。这对双胞胎中的任何一个，更不用说两个一起，所受的伤绝不可能是意外造成的，这简直是不可能的。所以无论谁干的，都是蓄意的。法庭听说，婴儿遭受了巨大的脑损伤，他们的胸部被紧紧抓握，以至于肋骨断裂，并且被猛烈撞击到硬物表面。这些小小的身体身上也带有其他虐待的痕迹。但陪审团被告知，没有任何医疗手段能够挽救婴儿的生命。这段视频以及本集将播放的所有未来视频
a courtesy of New Zealand radio links will be provided in the show notes so you can check out all their clips and articles that cover the case now the part you just heard about Maxina allegedly confessing to a defence witness will be covered shortly to call that alleged confession unreliable he's probably been too kind Maxina was one of the first prosecution witnesses to give evidence the mother of the car to Kahui twins has told the court how she argued with her partner after coming home to find her babies critically injured Maxina King was giving evidence at the trial of the baby's father Chris Kahui who was charged with their murder the crown alleges that Mr Kahui fatally injured the twins when he was alone with them in the baby's nursery back in
节目 show notes 中将提供新西兰广播电台（New Zealand Radio）相关链接，方便大家查看所有报道该案件的剪辑和文章。现在，我们即将聊到刚才听到的内容：关于玛克西娜（Maxina）涉嫌向辩护证人供认不讳的细节。如果要说那起所谓的供认不可靠，那这种说法可能还算是太客气了。玛克西娜是首批出庭作证的控方证人之一，这对卡胡伊（Kahui）双胞胎的母亲在法庭上讲述了她回家发现孩子们身受重伤后，如何与伴侣发生争吵的经过。玛克西娜·金（Maxina King）是在这起案件的庭审中出庭作证的，被告是双胞胎的父亲克里斯·卡胡伊（Chris Kahui），他被控谋杀这两个孩子。控方指控，卡胡伊先生在婴儿房里独自和孩子们在一起时，对这对双胞胎痛下杀手，时间是在
June 2006 and reported Joy Reed has been at the high court in Auckland she's with us now Joy what else did Miss King have to say well she described the last time that she saw the babies before they were injured she said that when she left them they were good they were awake looks normal their eyes were following sound and they were in good condition but she never saw them that way again now she left the house for the night the crown says the fatal injuries were inflicted and when she came back the next morning she was told that her son crew had stopped breathing during the night and she rushed into the nursery yelling at Chris and said this to the court I asked them what was happening while I was gone in a way how the hell did our baby our boy get that new bruise on his face and
2006年6月。据本台记者乔伊·里德（Joy Reed）报道，她一直在奥克兰高等法院旁听，现在她也来到了我们身边。乔伊，金女士还说了些什么？嗯，她描述了双胞胎受伤前她最后一次见到他们的情景。她说，当她离开时，孩子们状态很好，醒着，看起来很正常，眼睛会随着声音转动，身体状况也很棒。但她再也没有看到他们健康时的样子了。当时她离开家过夜，控方表示，致命伤正是在这段时间造成的。第二天早上她回来时，有人告诉她，她的儿子克鲁（Cru）在夜里停止了呼吸。她冲进婴儿房，冲着克里斯大喊。她在法庭上这样陈述：“我问他我不在的时候发生了什么，我们的小宝宝、我们的男孩脸上的新淤青到底是怎么弄的？”
what the hell happened and what did he say about the bruise Chris told me that it was our son Shane that did that I asked him how the hell how did he do that and then and then he told me he left the door to the nursery open that Shane had crawled in crawled in got into the room climbed up on the couch and had run along on top of the couch then she said that Chris Kahui blamed her for the babies stopping breathing and said that she should have been there taking care of the kids that otherwise this wouldn't have happened now as you've heard the prosecution's position was that the twins didn't have their injuries when Maxina left their house that day they couldn't have because April fed crew after Maxina had left and there is no way crew would be able to feed with the injuries he later
“到底发生了什么？”克里斯是怎么回答这个淤青的？克里斯告诉我，那是我们的儿子肖恩（Shane）干的。我问他怎么可能，他怎么做到的？然后他告诉我，他把婴儿房的门开着，肖恩爬了进去，爬进房间，爬上了沙发，还在沙发顶上跑来跑跑去。接着她说，克里斯·卡胡伊指责她导致孩子们停止呼吸，说她本该留在家里照顾孩子，否则这一切就不会发生。正如大家所听到的，控方的立场是：当玛克西娜那天离开家时，这对双胞胎身上并没有伤。他们不可能受伤，因为在玛克西娜离开后，阿普里尔（April）还喂过克鲁，带着后来受下的那些伤，克鲁根本不可能吃得下奶。
sustained Chris himself said that he had fed them after April had left as well so the defense tried to exploit the brief window of time when Chris was dropping Manor at the hospital around 7 p.m. that night remember he said he was gone for 20 minutes stewart king said it was more like 10 to 15 minutes police actually later did a test drive of the journey and including a stop for petrol they were there and back in 17 minutes so it's in this window of time the defense argued that Maxina could have returned home and inflicted the injuries on the twins Maxina and the prosecution of course rejected these claims Maxina saying she wasn't even in Mangaree at all that night but a point of contention which should never have been a point of contention was cell phone
克里斯自己也说，在阿普里尔离开后，他也喂过孩子们。因此，辩护律师试图利用那段短暂的时间窗口——也就是那天晚上7点左右，克里斯开车送曼娜（Mana）去医院的时间。记住，他说他离开了20分钟。斯图尔特·金（Stuart King）则说，那更像是10到15分钟。警方后来实际上对这段行程进行了实地测试，其中包括中途加油的时间，结果显示他们来回只用了17分钟。辩护方辩称，正是在这个时间窗口内，玛克西娜可能回过家，并对双胞胎下了毒手。玛克西娜和控方当然拒绝接受这些说法，玛克西娜坚称她那天晚上根本不在曼格雷（Mangere）。然而，有一个本不该成为争议焦点的争议点，那就是
records obtained from Maxina's sister Emily who Maxina said she was with the entire night a seed of doubt was planted by Emily's cell phone records Maxina said she didn't return to Courtney Crescent that night in fact she said she didn't return to Mangaree at all that night but Emily's cell phone records show she received a call at 7 54 p.m. and the call went through the Mangaree cell phone tower so at first glance the cell phone records indicate Maxina might have been in Mangaree that night after all and she might have been lying what actually happened was that Maxina and Emily were driving along the southwestern motorway past Mangaree and that's when Emily got the call that's why the call pinged off the Mangaree cell phone tower
从玛克西娜的妹妹埃米莉（Emily）那里获取的手机通话记录。玛克西娜曾说她整晚都和埃米莉在一起。埃米莉的手机通话记录却种下了怀疑的种子。玛克西娜说她那天晚上没有回考特尼新月街（Courtney Crescent），事实上，她坚称自己当晚根本没回过曼格雷。但埃米莉的手机记录显示，她在晚上7点54分接到过一个电话，该通话信号是通过曼格雷的手机基站传输的。所以初看之下，手机记录表明玛克西娜那天晚上可能确实在曼格雷，她可能在撒谎。但实际情况是，玛克西娜和埃米莉当时正开着车沿着西南高速公路（Southwestern Motorway）驶过曼格雷，埃米莉正是在那时接到了电话，这就是为什么通话信号会由曼格雷的手机基站转发。
and there was evidence to back this up what the court heard was that had the call been received by Emily while her and Maxina were at 22 Courtney Crescent in Mangaree which is what the defence were saying then the call wouldn't have even pinged off the Mangaree tower it would have pinged off another tower altogether it's a little confusing i can see how at first glance people would think no she's lying the cell phone records show that she was in Mangaree but actually they weren't they were driving past on the motorway and the cell phone records back up their story i can see how people get slipped up by that it's logical to assume that if they were at 22 Courtney Crescent Mangaree then a cell phone call would ping off the Mangaree tower but it's just
而且有证据支持这一说法。法庭听到的是，如果埃米莉是在曼格雷考特尼新月街22号接到这个电话的——正如辩方所言——那么这个通话甚至根本不会触发曼格雷基站的信号，而是会触发完全不同的另一个基站的信号。这确实有点让人迷惑，我完全能理解为什么大家第一眼会觉得：“不对，她在撒谎，手机记录显示她当时在曼格雷。”但实际上并非如此，她们当时正开车经过高速公路，手机通话记录也印证了她们的说法。我能理解人们为什么会被这一点带偏：顺理成章地假设如果她们当时在曼格雷考特尼新月街22号，手机通话就会连接到曼格雷的基站，但事情往往就是
one of those things that doesn't not to mention this particular call was received at 7 54 p.m Chris left for the hospital at 7 p.m and he said he was gone for 20 minutes so by his own evidence he was already back at home by 7 54 p.m and at 6 58 p.m which is around the time Chris left cell phone records place Emily and Maxina in a town 25 kilometers away which is around 15 miles so there's no way they could have got there in time while Chris was out so this theory using the cell phone records to support it is a stretch Chris's defense team went after Maxina hard and as i've said she certainly wasn't an angel she did have a criminal history for fraud and stealing and she had three children to two previous
这种巧合之一。更不用说，这个特定的电话是在晚上7点54分接到的。克里斯在晚上7点离开去医院，他说他离开了20分钟。因此，根据他自己的证词，到晚上7点54分时，他已经回到家了。而在晚上6点58分左右——也就是克里斯离开的时间前后，手机记录显示埃米莉和玛克西娜身处25公里（约15英里）外的一个小镇。因此，在克里斯外出期间，她们根本不可能来得及赶回去。所以，企图利用手机记录来支撑这一理论简直是无稽之谈。克里斯的辩护团队对玛克西娜穷追猛打。正如我所说，她当然不是什么圣人，她确实有诈骗和偷窃的前科，而且她与前两任
partners that were no longer in her care chain had since been removed from her and Chris's care as well given what happened to the twins the previous injuries found on the twins were obviously used against her people were asking how could a loving mother not notice these previous injuries Maxina was pained as promiscuous a violent bully and as someone who didn't care about her children there were even question marks raised if Chris was the father of the twins again making out she was out sleeping around but a paternity test ended that debate Chris was definitely the father and then came out that after the twins funeral Maxina got blown drunk made a fool of herself and it was alleged she started hitting on a female guest at the funeral
伴侣所生的三个孩子也早已不在她身边抚养。肖恩后来也被带离了她和克里斯的监护权。鉴于双胞胎身上发生的惨剧，双胞胎身上发现的先前伤痕显然成了攻击她的把柄。人们纷纷质问：一个慈爱的母亲怎么会没有注意到这些早前的伤痕？玛克西娜被刻画成了一个私生活混乱、凶残霸道、对孩子漠不关心的女人。甚至还有人对克里斯是否是这对双胞胎的亲生父亲打上了问号，再次暗示她在外面乱搞男女关系。不过，亲子鉴定终结了这场争论：克里斯绝对是亲生父亲。随后还爆出消息称，在双胞胎的葬礼后，玛克西娜喝得酩酊大醉，当众出丑，据称她还开始向葬礼上的一位女性宾客调情，
and ended up kissing Chris's teenage brother the hospital staff testified to painting a bad picture of her behavior at the hospital when she was there with the twins which she freely admits probably didn't look great the media lapped it up Maxina was the main target she was being crucified Chris seemed to escape much of the media crucifixion they painted a picture of Maxina as always being out partying never around for her children and being a drug user she did admit to trying drugs but says it definitely wasn't a regular thing Chris himself said he didn't know Maxina to be a drug user and Chris's own sister Mona testified that Maxina never really went out much at all
最后甚至亲吻了克里斯的 teenage 弟弟。医院工作人员出庭作证，勾勒出她在医院陪伴双胞胎时行为不端的糟糕形象，而她对此也供认不讳，承认当时的行为可能确实不太好看。媒体对此大肆炒作，玛克西娜成了众矢之的，遭到了口诛笔伐。相比之下，克里斯似乎逃过了大部分媒体的口诛笔伐。媒体将玛克西娜描绘成一个整日外出鬼混、对孩子不闻不问、还有毒瘾的女人。她确实承认自己尝试过毒品，但坚称这绝对不是常态。克里斯本人也说他并不知道玛克西娜吸毒，而克里斯自己的姐姐莫娜（Mona）也出庭作证说，玛克西娜其实根本不怎么出门。
then headline started surfacing saying Maxina had secretly admitted to a next boyfriend that she killed the twins and Chris had nothing to do with it this is the confession to the defense witness that you heard mentioned earlier apparently he had even tape recorded the admission only problem when it came time to produce the tape recording it didn't exist and her ex-boyfriend actually later testified he couldn't remember exactly what Maxina had said and he could have a mistaken he also admitted that he wasn't very good at telling the truth so he had zero credibility but it was just another piece used against Maxina in the defense's mission to make her
随后，各大媒体头条开始浮出水面，称玛克西娜曾私下向一位前男友承认，是她杀害了双胞胎，而克里斯对此一无所知。这就是前面提到的、向辩护证人做出的供认。据说这位前男友甚至还把这段供认录了音。唯一的矛盾在于，当需要出示录音时，根本拿不出来。而且这位前男友后来在作证时承认，他记不清玛克西娜到底说过什么了，自己也可能会记错。他还承认自己不太擅长说实话，因此毫无可信度。但这不过是辩护方旨在将玛克西娜
out to be the killer people read the headline and the article and think it must be true never mind that when you look into it it becomes apparent it was about as far from the truth as you could get the mother of the dead kahuwi twins will face a further grilling in the witness stand today as if the defense tries to paint her as the baby's killer Maxina King's giving evidence at the trial of the twins father Chris kahuwi who's accused of murdering the three-month-old babies in June of 2006 Maxina King will spend a third day in the witness box today reported Joy Reed is covering the trial the defense was unrelenting in its questioning of Maxina King
包装成凶手这一阴谋中，用来攻击她的又一枚筹码。人们读到头条新闻和文章，便信以为真，却不管当你深入调查时，就会发现这与真相相去甚远。这对死去的卡胡伊双胞胎的母亲今天将在证人席上面对新一轮的严厉盘问，因为辩护方正试图将她描绘成婴儿的杀害元凶。玛克西娜·金正在这对双胞胎的父亲克里斯·卡胡伊的庭审中作证，克里斯被指控在2006年6月谋杀这三个月大的婴儿。玛克西娜·金今天将在证人席上度过第三天。据本台记者乔伊·里德报道，辩护方对玛克西娜·金的盘问毫不留情，
accusing her of being the twins killer put it to you that you returned home and you lost it that's not true i put it to you that you did something terrible to the twins i have never ever absolutely not harmed my sons defense lawyer Lorraine Smith said Maxina King had told her sisters that a woman with evil spirits had hurt the babies hinting at herself but Miss King says that was absolutely untrue she also denies the allegations that she had two opportunities to injure the babies either on the morning before they were admitted to hospital or while Chris was out the day she says she wasn't at home she also denies confessing to another boyfriend that she was the killer you said to him oh i don't know why i'd done what i did didn't you it's absolutely
指控她就是双胞胎的凶手。“我向你指出，你回到家后情绪失控了。”“这不是真的。”“我向你指出，你对这对双胞胎做了可怕的事情。”“我从来、从来、绝对没有伤害过我的儿子们。”辩护律师洛林·史密斯（Lorraine Smith）称，玛克西娜·金曾对她的姐妹们说，是一个带有邪灵的女人伤害了这些孩子，这暗示了她自己。但金女士坚称这绝对是无稽之谈。她还否认了以下指控：即她有两次伤害双胞胎的机会——一次是在他们被送往医院的那天早晨，另一次是在克里斯外出的那天。她坚称自己当时根本不在家。她同样否认曾向另一位前男友坦白自己是凶手。“你对他说过‘我不知道自己为什么要做出那种事’，不是吗？”“这绝对
not true he said to you done what man what are you on about didn't he no you said oh never mind and you also said Chris didn't do it didn't you that's absolutely not true Maxina King also denied trying to cover up historical bruises with makeup and heavy handling her other son who was just three months old at the time she also rejected claims that she tried to make the twins look cared for by washing the unconscious babies before taking them to hospital and that she threatened her brother with a bullet if he told police what happened the defense also tried to paint Miss King as a careless mother he had six children all together haven't you yes to a deceased Shane has been taken away from you by sips hasn't he Shane's been removed from the
不是真的。”“他对你说‘做了什么吗？你在胡说八道些什么？’难道不是吗？”“没有，你说了‘哦，算了吧’。你还说过‘克里斯没有这么做’，不是吗？”“这绝对不是真的。”玛克西娜·金还否认曾试图用粉妆遮盖历史淤青，也否认粗暴对待当时只有三个月大的另一个儿子。她还反驳了以下说法：即她曾试图通过在把失去知觉的婴儿送往医院前给他们洗澡，来制造双胞胎受到精心照顾的假象，以及她曾用一颗子弹威胁她的兄弟，不准向警方吐露实情。辩护方还试图将金女士刻画成一个粗心的母亲。“你总共生了六个孩子，对吧？”“是的。”“和已故的肖恩，他已经被儿童福利部门带走了，对吧？肖恩已经被……”
yes the older three are from two previous relationships aren't they yes they are and you abandoned those three older children uh with their fathers didn't you i left them in the best possible care that was best for them at the time especially when she admitted to using the drunk pee the week before taking the babies to hospital you looked after the twins while you was still under the influence of methamphetamine didn't you yep Maxina King no longer has any contact with any of her four remaining children she told the court Chris Kahoe was a loving father who was always worried about handling the twins because they were so tiny her cross examination continues today in Auckland from warning report joy raid
“是的。”“较大的三个孩子来自两段之前的恋爱关系，对吧？”“是的，没错。”“而你把那三个较大的孩子抛弃在……和他们的父亲在一起，对吧？”“我把他们留在了当时对他们最好的、尽可能最好的照顾中，这对他们来说是最好的。”特别是当她承认在把孩子送往医院前一周还在吸食冰毒时：“你在受到甲基安非タミン（冰毒）影响的情况下照顾这对双胞胎，对吧？”“是的。”玛克西娜·金目前与剩余的四个孩子中的任何一个都没有任何联系。她告诉法庭，克里斯·卡胡伊是一个慈爱的父亲，总是担心自己抱双胞胎时不够小心，因为他们实在太小了。对她的盘问今天在奥克兰继续进行。本台记者乔伊·里德发自现场。
many others were called to the standard testifier here is Stuart King testifying about the incident where crews stopped breathing it was a lips red like a dark purple they kept on getting darker and darker and darker and this his body was so so flimsy and so limp wasn't the teller was it normal how long wasn't he breathing for breathing for about five ten minutes oh now he was just blowing in my arms loathless and all importantly the jury got to hear from Chris Kahoe he didn't testify at his trial he had every right to remain silent and not testify but his police interviews were played to the court the jury and the trial of double murder accused Chris Kahoe has today been watching police videos
许多其他人也被传唤出庭作证。这里是斯图尔特·金在作证，讲述克鲁停止呼吸的那起事件：“他的嘴唇红得像深紫色，颜色越来越深、越来越深、越来越深。他的身体太软了、太绵软了，一点力气都没有。”那不是正常的颜色，对吧？他停止呼吸有多久了？呼吸大约持续了五到十分钟。哦，当时他只是无力地躺在我的怀里，毫无生息。最重要的是，陪审团听取了克里斯·卡胡伊的陈述。他在庭审中没有出庭作证，他完全有权保持沉默并不作证，但他在警方的录像访谈在法庭上被播放了。被控双重谋杀的克里斯·卡胡伊的庭审陪审团今天一直在观看警方录像，
in which he describes how bruises started to sprout on his babies three month old twins Chris and crew Kahoe died of severe head injuries in June 2006 our reporter Joy Reed has been in the high court in Auckland watching the videos today she's with us now Joy what does Chris Kahoe say in this well there are about six hours of footage in total and so far the juries only watched about three hours of them but in the accused first interview with police which was only hours after the twins were admitted to hospital he's got his one-year-old son sitting there on his knee and it's in that interview that Chris Kahoe told the police officer that baby crew had stopped breathing during the night and that his lips went blue he was breathing on the lips and then I put
视频中他描述了三个月大的双胞胎婴儿——克里斯和克鲁——身上是如何开始长出淤青的。克里斯和克鲁于2006年6月死于严重的头部损伤。本台记者乔伊·里德今天一直在奥克兰高等法院观看这些视频。她现在和我们在一起。乔伊，克里斯·卡胡伊在视频里说了什么？嗯，录像总共有大约六个小时的素材，到目前为止，陪审团只观看了大约三个小时。但在被告与警方的首次访谈中——那是在双胞胎被送往医院仅几个小时后，他的1年岁儿子正坐在他的膝头。正是在那次访谈中，克里斯·卡胡伊告诉警官，婴儿克鲁在夜里停止了呼吸，嘴唇发青。他在嘴唇上做人工呼吸，然后我
my head to his mouth and he wasn't breathing so I gave him like a bit of CPR and five breaths and one pump and he came right inside the breathing unit now Chris Kahoe said that was pretty freaky in his own words but that baby crew as I said did come right and it wasn't until about 10 the next the next morning that Chris Kahoe noticed any bruises on the boys and I sort of see some bruising on Chris's face and at the time you saw the bruising come up on Chris what did you think so by lunch time there were more bruises and later on as I say more bruises sprouted up on both those boys' faces and how did he explain the injuries well in a word he couldn't and he said at one stage though that his son Shane who was this one-year-old toddler might have gone in there and
把头贴到他的嘴上，发现他没有呼吸，所以我给他做了一点心肺复苏（CPR），吹了五次气，按压了一次，呼吸机里的心跳就恢复正常了。克里斯·卡胡伊说，用他自己的话说，那“相当诡异”，但正如我所说，婴儿克鲁确实恢复了正常。直到第二天早上10点左右，克里斯·卡胡伊才注意到男孩身上有任何淤青。“我看到克里斯（注：此处指双胞胎中的哥哥Chris）的脸上有一些淤青。”在你看到克里斯身上的淤青浮现时，你作何感想？到了午饭时间，出现了更多的淤青；后来，正如我所说，两个男孩的脸上冒出了更多的淤青。他是如何解释这些伤势的呢？嗯，一言以蔽之，他解释不了。不过他一度表示，他那一岁的幼儿儿子肖恩可能走进房间，
quote whacked the twins but when asked if he actually saw Shane hit the twins he said that he hadn't he'd just seen him go into the twins room but that Shane had hit the boys before by accident and when police officer a detective Julie Ingram put to him that the injuries were so severe that there's no way Shane could have caused him he didn't have anything to say to that and then she said quote someone's gone in and beaten your boys who was that and Chris Kahoe said he didn't know now Detective Ingram asked him if he had got angry and he'd taken it out on the boys to which he replied I've never hit a kid before I've never hit my boys and I've never hit any child what did he say then about the twins and how they usually behaved well he said they spent most of the time
“狠狠地打了”这对双胞胎。但当被问及他是否亲眼看到肖恩打双胞胎时，他说他没有，他只看到肖恩走进过双胞胎的房间，而且肖恩以前也偶然打过男孩们。当女警探朱莉·英格拉姆（Julie Ingram）向他指出，这些伤势如此严重，肖恩根本不可能造成时，他对此无话可说。接着女警探说：“有人进去殴打你的孩子，那是谁？”克里斯·卡胡伊说他不知道。英格拉姆警探随后问他是否因愤怒而把气撒在孩子身上，对此他回答说：“我以前从没打过小孩，我从没打过我的男孩们，我也从没打过任何儿童。”那他随后对双胞胎及其平时的表现是怎么说的呢？嗯，他说他们大部分时间都待在
in the cot unless they were feeding and that was every six hours or so but he did say that baby Chris was often unsettled that he was the one that normally cried a lot more and he described the crying as grizzling now we know now that baby Chris was actually nursing a broken leg during that time and that broken leg was up to two weeks old before he was hospitalized with the fatal head injuries and what was Chris Kahoe's demeanor like in these videos he's very quietly spoken and on the whole seemed relatively calm at one stage though the police officer told him that his babies may not survive and asked him if he was concerned about this and he said that yes yes he's very scared he spent much of the first interview cuddling his one-year-old son Shane
婴儿床里，除非是在喂奶，大约每六个小时一次。但他确实提到，婴儿克里斯经常显得烦躁不安，是那个通常哭得更多的孩子，他把这种哭声描述为“唠叨般的哭闹”。现在我们知道，婴儿克里斯当时其实正带着一条骨折的腿。在因致命头部损伤住院之前，那条断腿已经骨折长达两周之久。克里斯·卡胡伊在这些视频中的表现如何？他说话声音很轻，总体上显得相对冷静。不过，一度有警官告诉他，他的孩子们可能无法存活，并问他是否对此感到担忧，他回答说“是的，是的，他非常害怕”。在第一次访谈的大部分时间里，他都在深情地搂抱着他一岁的儿子肖恩，
and the rest of the video footage which is without his younger son will be played tomorrow thank you joy that's our reporter in Auckland joy read video evidence has continued today in the Kahoe case with footage showing Chris Kahoe denying he had fatally injured his twins in a fit of rage it's likely to be the only time the jury will hear directly from the accused whose charge was murdering his twin boys Chris and crew in June 2006 the video interview has today also revealed the accused admitted he wanted to hand himself into police because he felt he had nothing left to live for our reporter joy read has been in court watching that footage today she's with us now joy how else does he explain the
其余没有他小儿子画面的录像带将于明天播放。谢谢你，乔伊，这是我们的奥克兰记者乔伊·里德。卡胡伊案的视频证据今天仍在继续播放，画面显示克里斯·卡胡伊否认自己在狂怒之下对双胞胎下了致命毒手。这很可能是陪审团唯一一次直接听到被告本人的声音。他被控于2006年6月谋杀了他的一对双胞胎儿子克里斯和克鲁。今天的视频访谈还透露，被告承认他曾想向警方自首，因为他觉得自己已经生无可恋。本台记者乔伊·里德今天一直在法庭观看这段录像，她现在和我们在一起。乔伊，他在最后这段视频访谈中，对双胞胎的伤势还有什么其他的解释吗？
twins injuries in this final video interview well he doesn't really he repeatedly says that he doesn't know that or how his his boys were hurt and the detective interviewing him pushed him quite hard on this and during the interview he admitted that he was under a lot of pressure from the twins mother maxina king at the time that she was upset with him for spending so much time at the hospital with his sick mother instead of with her at home he admitted that he bottled things up that he was angry that maxina king had gone out for the night and then detective sergeant chris barry suggested to him that all these factors combined caused him to snap pressure with three kids mum's in hospital banjo's having to go with you there's no one else to take it how wrong
嗯，他其实没有什么新解释。他反复说他不知道、也不知道他的男孩们是如何受伤的。负责审问他的女警探对此进行了相当严厉的逼问，而在访谈中他承认，当时他承受着来自双胞胎母亲玛克西娜·金的巨大压力。因为他花太多时间在医院陪伴生病的母亲，而不是在家陪她，玛克西娜对此感到很不满。他承认自己总是把事情憋在心里，因为玛克西娜·金彻夜不归而感到愤怒。随后，侦探警长克里斯·巴里（Chris Barry）向他指出，所有这些因素交织在一起，导致他情绪崩溃：“压力，三个孩子，妈妈在医院，还得跟着你去（医院），没有别人能承担这一切……多大的错误……你的挫败感在一个你失去控制的时刻爆发了。所以，到底发生了什么？”
your frustration comes out in a moment where you lose control so what happened now he repeatedly denied similar accusations today in court on the video including those that he didn't call an ambulance when baby crew stopped breathing that night and he didn't go to the hospital when they were first admitted to intensive care and the policeman put it to him this was because he had caused the fatal injuries to which he said it wasn't true how then does he try to justify his statements about wanting to hand himself in well the court hurt that he told his dad and maxina king's brother stewart that he felt responsible for the
随后，他在今天的法庭视频中多次否认了类似的指控，包括当晚婴儿克鲁停止呼吸时他没有叫救护车，以及在他们最初被送入重症监护室时他没有去医院。警察质问他这是因为他造成了致命伤，对此他回答说“这不是真的”。那他后来又是如何试图为自己想要自首的言论辩解的呢？嗯，法庭获悉，他曾对父亲和玛克西娜·金的兄弟斯图尔特说，他觉得自己对双胞胎的死负有责任，因为他未能保护好自己的儿子，而且现在他们死了，他觉得生无可恋。那他有没有提到玛克西娜·金以及她涉嫌参与双胞胎受伤的事情呢？嗯，辩方声称，孩子的母亲玛克西娜·金是最有可能杀死婴儿的人。在这段与警方的最后访谈中，克里斯·卡胡伊暗示，是的，她确实可能是那个失去理智的人，并且在和妹妹外出过夜之前，正是她弄伤了双胞胎。但他无法提供更多细节来佐证这一说法，也无法就她为何应该承担责任提供更多细节。
twins deaths because he'd failed to protect his sons and that now that they're dead he's got nothing left to live for and does he say anything about maxina king and her alleged involvement in the twins injuries well the defense claims that the baby's mother maxina king is the most likely a one to have killed the infants and in this final interview with the police chris carhoi suggests that yes she could be the one to have lost control and that she was the one to injure the twins before they went out for them before she went out for the night with her sister but he couldn't go into more details to back that up and couldn't go into any more details about why she could be to blame and the jury had some medical pictures of the twins other injuries
陪审团昨天看到了双胞胎身上其他伤势的医学照片。法庭昨天是有史以来第一次看到双胞胎其他伤情严重程度的画面。今天，法庭展示了一张婴儿克里斯的X光片，片中显示他的腿部骨折，从这张X光片中可以清晰地看到这根骨头已经断成了两半，医学专家指出，这一伤情不到7到10天。此外，婴儿克里斯可能还有手腕骨折和头部骨折，婴儿克鲁也有一处头部骨折。谢谢你，乔伊，这是我们的奥克兰记者乔伊·里德。而辩方也迎来了他们传唤证人的时间。他们传唤了自己的专家，旨在反驳控方专家的证词，并进一步巩固他们的另一套理论——即如果玛克西娜在6月12日克里斯外出的那个短暂时间窗口内没有回过家，
yesterday the court was able to see for the very first time the extent of the twins other injuries today and it was shown an x-ray of baby chris who had a broken leg and in this x-ray you could physically see that this bone had been snapped in half and the the medical expert said that the injury was less than seven to ten days old now baby chris also had a possible wrist wrist fracture and a head fracture and baby crew also had a head fracture thank you joy that's our reporter and Auckland joy read and the defense had their turn calling witnesses they called in their own expert to refute what the prosecution experts had to say and to drive home their other theory which was that if maxina hadn't returned home in that brief window of time chris was out on
那么她一定是在离开之前或者在回家那天早上伤害了双胞胎。卡胡伊案辩方的关键医学证人今天对控方关于婴儿双胞胎致命伤受伤时间的说法提出了异议。特伦斯·唐纳德（Dr Terrence Donald）医生今天出庭作证，作为克里斯·卡胡伊案庭审中的最后一位辩护证人。克里斯·卡胡伊被指控在将近两年前谋杀了他的一对双胞胎男婴。案件目前已接近尾声，陪审团预计将于本周晚些时候退庭闭门评议并做出裁决。本台记者乔伊·里德今天一直在奥克兰高等法院旁听，她现在和我们在一起。乔伊，首先，唐纳德医生对双胞胎受伤时间的说法是什么？
the 12th of june then she must have injured the twins either before she left or the morning that she got home the key medical witness for the defense in the carhoi case has today disputed when the crown says the baby twins were fatally injured dr terrence donald gave evidence today as the last defense witness in the trial of chris carhoi who's accused of murdering his twin baby boys nearly two years ago the case is now winding up with the jury expected to go out later this week to consider its verdict our reporter joy read has been at the high court in Auckland today she's with us now joy firstly what did dr donald say about the timing of the twins injuries all the crown's cases that the infant's injuries can be narrowed down to just before baby crew stopped
嗯，控方的全部论点是，婴儿的受伤时间可以精确缩小到婴儿克鲁停止呼吸之前的那一刻，也就是被告独自在他们婴儿房呆过之后立即发生的。但来自澳大利亚的儿童虐待专家唐纳德医生今天表示，要准确指出这对双胞胎究竟是什么时候受伤的，其实“太难了”。他表示，他们有可能是在控方所说的时间受伤的，但更有可能是孩子们在早些时候的一次袭击中就已受伤，而这次呼吸暂停事件更像是癫痫发作以及对伤势的二次反应。这种情况同样也完全符合一个正在出现因先前某个时间发生的事情而引发的二次反应的婴儿的情况，你无法断言哪一种可能性更高。唐纳德医生说，一个不是他们主要照顾者的人——
breathing which was immediately after the accused spent time alone in their nursery but dr donald today he's a child abuse expert from australia says that it's it's too hard really to pinpoint when exactly these twins were injured now he says it is possible that they were hurt when the crown says they were but that it's more likely that the babies could have been injured in an earlier assault and that this breathing episode was more likely to be a seizure and a secondary reaction to the injuries it would also fit just as well with a baby who was developing secondary effects from something that had occurred sometime previously you couldn't argue one over the other now dr donald says that a person who was not their main carer
包括父亲在内（如果父亲不是主要照顾者的话），在他们遭受严重伤势时，可能并未察觉到他们有任何不对劲。那么他认为婴儿是什么时候受伤的呢？嗯，唐纳德医生今天向法庭明确表示，这很难说，并指出如果呼吸暂停事件是二次反应的话，它可能会在初次袭击（也就是初次受伤）后长达六个小时内发生。现在他表示，要准确测定婴儿受伤时间的唯一方法，就是从一个独立人士那里了解到双胞胎最后一次正常互动的时间，因为这意味着伤势必定发生在此之后。但他说，在本案中，实际上并没有独立人士，唯一能获得的描述，即双胞胎在控方称伤势发生之前是如何反应的，
including the father if the father wasn't the main caregiver may not have been aware of anything wrong with them when they had their serious injuries so when does he think the babies were injured well dr donald made it pretty clear to the court today that it's hard to say and says that if the breathing breathing episode was a secondary reaction then it could have occurred up to six hours after the primary assault which is the primary injury now said that the only way really to accurately time when the babies were injured is to find out from an independent person when the twins were last interacting normally as this would mean that the injuries would have happened after this but he says in this case there's effectively no independent person and the only
正是来自于双胞胎的母亲。他说，照顾者通常不被归类为“独立人士”。你认为能说清双胞胎是在2006年6月12日星期一的什么时候受伤的吗？这取决于他们母亲的陈述有多大可信度。如果他们母亲的陈述是可靠的，那么（受伤）就发生在那个时间点之后；如果他们母亲的陈述不可靠，那么它可能发生在那个时间点之前。关于双胞胎的伤势，他还说了些什么？嗯，他今天表示，他们的伤势非常严重且几乎一模一样。他还说，他相信他们本能够进行基本的喂养，但无法有力地吮吸。这与控方医学专家的说法有所不同，控方专家称，在遭受如此严重的头部损伤后，婴儿根本无法怎么吃奶。
real description that you get about about how the twins reacted earlier earlier before the crown says these injuries occurred is from the twins mother and he said that a carer is not usually classified as an independent you think it's possible to say when on monday the 12th of June 2006 the babies were injured that depends on how reliable their mother's account is if their mother's reliable account had happened after that if their mother's reliable account isn't reliable then it could have happened before that what else did he say about the twins injuries well he said today that their injuries were very serious and almost identical he also said that he believed that they would have been able to to do basic feeding but not vigorously suck but that differs
现在，他还表示，令他非常惊讶的是，直到这些婴儿被带去看医生之前，竟然没有人意识到他们病得有多重。他说，这些婴儿在长达数小时的时间里会处于半昏迷状态，无法唤醒，并会发出异常的声音。对于尸检，他有什么批评意见呢？嗯，他说这次尸检漏掉了很多步骤，比如检查婴儿的眼睛，这使得确定双胞胎是如何受伤变得更加困难。他曾在澳大利亚撰写过尸检规程，并表示这次解剖根本不符合那些标准。我们快要接近庭审尾声了吗？是的，没错。唐纳德医生是被传唤的最后一位辩护证人，因此从明天开始，控方将进行结案陈词，预计这将占据大部分时间；随后，辩护方的结案陈词将在周三进行；法官可能会在周四进行总结陈词，并让陪审团退庭审议裁决。
from the crown medical experts who say that the babies would not have been able to feed much at all after sustaining such serious head injuries now he also said that he was very surprised that no one realized how seriously ill these babies were until they were taken to the doctor and he said these babies would have been in and out of consciousness for many hours they would have been unable to wake and making abnormal noises and what criticism did he have about the autopsy well he says that a number of steps were missed out in this autopsy and such as examining the baby's eyes and that made it more difficult to try and determine how these twins were hurt now he's written a protocol for autopsies in Australia and said that this post-mortem would not have
谢谢你，乔伊，这是我们的奥克兰记者乔伊·里德。在法庭上陈述完所有证据后，轮到陪审团来决定克里斯·卡胡伊的命运了。但他们并没有花很长时间，事实上，他们以创纪录的速度做出了裁决。不可思议的是，他们仅仅用了几分钟就做出了决定。有人说只用了一分钟，也有人说比几分钟稍长一点。但法庭当时已经宣布休庭
met those standards and we are nearing the end of this yes we are dr donald was the last defense witness to be called so from tomorrow the crown will make its closing submissions and that's expected to take most of the day then the defense closing submissions will be on wednesday and the judge will probably sum up and send the jury out on thursday to consider its verdict thank you joy that's our reporter and Auckland joy read after all the evidence had been laid out in court it was time for the jury to decide the fate of Chris Kahui but they didn't need long in fact they reach a verdict in record time incredibly they came to their decision in just minutes some say it was only one minute but others say it was a few minutes more than that but the court had already adjourned
去吃午饭了，所以在宣读最终判决前，已经过去了一个多小时。你裁定被告克里斯托弗·桑尼·卡胡伊（Christopher Sonny Kahui）在第一项谋杀克鲁·奥梅卡·卡胡伊（Cru Omeka Kahui）的罪名上是有罪还是无罪？我们裁定被告无罪。你裁定被告克里斯托弗·桑尼·卡胡伊在第二项谋杀克里斯托弗·阿莱卡·卡胡伊（Christopher Alecah Kahui）的罪名上是有罪还是无罪？我们裁定被告无罪。无罪释放的日期是2008年5月22日。以下是卡胡伊的律师米歇尔·威尔金森·史密斯（Michelle Wilkinson Smith）的访谈。这些采访由新西兰电台（New Zealand Radio）提供。她首先谈到了陪审团做出裁决的速度之快。
for lunch so it was over an hour before the actual verdict was read do you find the accused Christopher Sonny Kahui guilty or not guilty on count one of the murder of crew or mecca Kahui we find the accused not guilty do you find the accused Christopher Sonny Kahui guilty or not guilty on count two of the murder of Christopher Alecah Kahui we have found the accused not guilty the date of acquittal was the 22nd of may 2008 here is what Kahui's lawyer Michelle Wilkinson Smith had to say these interviews are courtesy of New Zealand radio she starts by talking about how quickly the jury reached their verdict well it was a very long trial and during the trial they've
嗯，这是一场非常漫长的庭审，在庭审期间，他们显然有时间讨论出现的一些问题。所以据推测，他们已经讨论过很多事情了。当他们宣布裁决时，你的反应是什么？——感到巨大的释怀。你的当事人呢？——我想他的感受也差不多。他现在在做什么？——他和家人一起回家了。他对你说了什么？——他几乎没说什么，实际上几乎说不出话来。关于这个裁决，你认为他们是怎么得出这个结论的？——哦，我完全不知道。我们认为在每一个可能的方面都存在合理疑点，而陪审团大概也持相同看法。至关重要的是伤势发生的时间，
obviously had time to discuss some of the issues that arise um so presumably there are a lot of things that already discussed and your response when they delivered that verdict uh hugely relieved and what about your client I think he felt much the same what's he doing now he went home with a family what did he say to you he said very little he could barely speak actually the verdict how do you think they reached that oh I've got no idea um we we thought that there was reasonable doubt in every possible area and presumably the jury agreed crucially it was the timing of the injuries yes and whether it could be excluded um basically whether Chris Kahui was the only person who could possibly have inflicted the injuries now of course that raises the question
对吧？以及它是否能被排除……基本上就是克里斯·卡胡伊是否是唯一一个可能造成这些伤势的人。那么这当然引发了一个问题：究竟是谁造成了这些伤势？是的，我不能……我的意思是，这个问题在法庭内已经得到妥善推进，但我不能在法庭外谈论这个。但这本是你们辩护案的关键部分，你们把矛头指向了母亲。是的，我的意思是……案件的审理方式纯粹是对我们手头证据的回应。但这肯定……出于大家心知肚明的场外原因，我真的不能过多谈论到底是谁干的。所以从这个角度来看，这里并没有一个彻底的真相大白。好吧，我的意思是，刑事司法系统能做的唯一事情就是依据证据工作。不幸的是，在某些情况下，并没有绝对的证据来证明谁做出了这种事，这非常非常悲哀，但这正是现实。因为
of who did inflict the injuries yeah and I can't really I mean that's advanced inside the courtroom quite properly but I can't talk about that outside the courtroom but it was a crucial part of your case you pointed the finger at the mother yeah I think I mean the way the case was run was simply a response to the evidence that we had um but it's certainly not I can't outside the courtroom reasons I'm sure you're aware of um really talk about who might actually have done it so in that way there's no resolution here well I mean all the the only thing that the criminal justice system can do is work with evidence and unfortunately in some cases there is no absolute you know proof as to who has done something like this and that's very very sad but that's just the reality because
到头来，你只能基于“排除合理怀疑”的证据给某人定罪。如果没有这样的证据，把一个清白的人送进监狱就谈不上什么正义。关于对本案中警方起诉工作的批评，你是在暗示克里斯·卡胡伊本不该被起诉吗？我认为，庭审期间提出的批评是陪审团应当听取的，因为这是一个纯粹的 circumstantial case（间接证据案/情理案），问题在于陪审团对他们是否已完全掌握所有情况能有多大信心。不过，警方总是在他们手头证据的范围内尽力而为，他们按照自己看到的样子陈述案件，然后控方按照控方看到的样子陈述案件，而整个
in the end you can only convict someone of this proof beyond reasonable doubt and if there isn't there's no justice in sending someone to prison for something they didn't do the criticism of the police prosecution in this are you suggesting that Chris Kahui should never have been charged I think the criticism that was levelled during the case was appropriate for the jury to hear about because it was a circumstantial case and it's a question of how confident that the jury could be that they were were fully praised of all the circumstances however the police always do their best within the I think within the evidence that they have and they present their case as they see it and then the crown presents the case as the crown sees it and the
系统理应包含安全机制，因此控方会审查警方的案件，这其中就存在一道安全机制。但当然，没有人是完美的，人们难免会犯错，这就是我们拥有司法系统的全部原因——系统里同时还配备了辩护律师，他们会提出另一套视角，有能力审视证据并说：“等等，这好像说不通。”然后我们还有陪审团，他们最终是终极的安全机制。我认为这个案子真正说明了这一系统能运转得多么良好，尽管它耗费了很长的时间，而且外界对刑事审判的运作方式有各种批评，但到头来，你绝不可能找到比12名并不总是盯着案件看的普通人更公正的群体了。
system is supposed to have safeguards in it so the crown reviews the police case and there's a safeguard there but of course you know nobody is perfect and people do make mistakes that's the whole reason we have a justice system that also has defense counsel who then put the other side who have the ability to look at the evidence who can say look hang on that doesn't quite work and then we have the jury who in the end of the ultimate safeguard and I think this case really illustrates how well the system can work you know despite the fact it takes a long time and of all the criticism of the way criminal trials are run you know you're not going to get any more impartial people in the end than 12 ordinary people who do not watch cases all the time
或者，这也是对警方运作调查方式的一种批评？嗯，你难道认为警方总能把事情办对吗？如果你说警方必须永远正确、绝不应该出现无罪判决，那基本上就等于说我们不需要刑事司法系统了，警方直接把所有人抓起来扔进监狱就行了。我们整个系统的假设就是：警方不可能永远正确。他们当然不会永远正确。同样，不幸的是，在这起男孩被杀的悲剧里，我们并不知道答案。不，我们不知道。这绝对是一场悲剧，而且……我的意思是，我有三种想法……我觉得这个案子里的某些事件相当艰难，我想很多人都有同感。这非常非常悲哀，而且……你知道的，
or it could be a criticism of the way the police run investigations well do you think the police always to get it right I mean if you say the police must always get it right and they should never be a not guilty then basically what you're saying is we don't need a criminal justice system the police can get the rest of them and put them in prison our whole system assumes that the police will not always get it right well of course they won't and again unfortunately in this case the tragedy of these boys being killed we don't know the answer no we don't um and it is an absolute tragedy and you know I mean I've got three thoughts I've found it quite difficult some of the events in this case I think lots of people have it's very very sad and and you know
这个判决太棒了，我们对这个判决感到非常宽慰，但这永远无法抹去这样一个事实：有两个婴儿已经失去了生命。而且我必须再次指出，辩护方曾称警方的调查是一场“灾难”，这可不仅仅是犯了个错误。警方的调查中确实有一些方面，辩护方认为本应该做得更好。好吧，“灾难”这个词是法庭上使用的，对吧？我当时在法庭上并没有用这个词。我的意思是，这或许是另一个场合才该讨论的问题。作为辩护律师，我们是从我们的角度和目标来看待这个问题的：不管它是不是一场灾难，其实并不是我们最终要审视的重点，我们只是把这些呈献给陪审团。我们不知道
the verdict is great we've very relieved at the verdict but it never um takes away from the fact that there are um you know there's two babies who've died and again I have to point out the defence called the police investigation a disaster which is not merely making a mistake there were aspects of the police investigation that certainly the defence thought should have been done better well disaster was the word that was used in court yeah it wasn't I didn't use that word there I mean that's probably an issue for another forum you know we're the defence council we're looking at it from our point of view and our objective we are about whether it was a disaster or not it's not really for us to look at in the end we put that before the jury we don't know
陪审团从中吸收了多少，但正如你所说，这个案子对你造成了沉重的心理负担。哦，这是一个漫长的案子。我想，所有涉案人员，包括陪审团在内，都觉得非常……我的意思是，这真的很悲哀。你看着所有这些婴儿的照片，真的非常非常悲哀，这是毫无疑问的。这对克里斯·卡胡伊来说很悲哀，对整个家族来说都很悲哀。而且，无论谁干的……从来没有人暗示这是一场冷血谋杀。无论谁干的，绝对都是在精神崩溃、无法应对的情况下失控了。你知道，公众高呼复仇是可以理解的，我明白这一点；但去看看现有的那些支持系统吧，看看有多少援助是留给那些带着小婴儿的人们的——婴儿不会因为哭泣而死，把他们放下，走开就是了。
how much the jury took from that but as you say it's taken a toll on you this case oh it's a long case I think it's I think everyone involved in it including the jury it's very I mean it's just sad you know you've got photos of all of the babies it's very very sad there's no two ways about it it's sad for Chris Kahui um sad for the whole family and you know whoever did this there's never really been a suggestion that this was a cold-blooded murder whoever did this absolutely snapped because they weren't coping and you know public calling up for vengeance is fine I understand it but go look at the systems that are in place and how much assistance there is and for people out there with little babies you know they don't die of crying just put them down and walk away
陪审团从中领会了多少很难说，但正如你所说，这个案件对你造成了沉重的打击。哦，这是一个漫长的案件，我认为参与其中的每个人，包括陪审团在内，我都觉得……我的意思是这真的很悲伤，你知道的，你手里有所有婴儿的照片，这真的非常非常悲伤，这是毫无疑问的。这对克里斯·卡胡伊来说很悲伤，嗯，对整个家庭来说也很悲伤，你知道的，无论谁做了这件事，其实从来没有人认为这是一起冷血谋杀。无论谁做这件事，绝对是因为无法应对而彻底崩溃了，你知道的，公众呼吁复仇是可以理解的，我能理解，但去看看现有的系统以及有多少援助吧，对于那些带着小婴儿的人来说，你知道的，婴儿不会因为哭泣而死，只要把他们放下然后走开就行了。
what would you say about the effect that this has had on on Chris Kahui it's really hard to tell he's grown up a lot in the course of the trial you know he was 21 when it started 23 now and they're quite important years um I think he's handled it with surprising dignity he's been a very easy client to deal with and I hope that he can move on from this and rebuild his life and I hope that the fact that he's recognizable everywhere isn't going to hold him back too much that's Michelle Wilkinson Smith the lawyer for Chris Kahui who's been acquitted of murdering his two baby sons here is what Detective Inspector John Timms had to say after the verdict I think it's important and I think the message needs to be made clear that everyone that was at Courtney
你对这件事对克里斯·卡胡伊（Chris Kahui）产生的影响怎么看？这真的很难说。在审判过程中他成熟了很多，你知道他开始时21岁，现在23岁，这些都是非常重要的几年。嗯，我认为他以一种令人惊讶的尊严处理了这件事，他是一个非常容易打交道的当事人，我希望他能从这件事中走出来，重建自己的生活，我也希望他无处不在的辨识度不会给他带来太多阻碍。这是克里斯·卡胡伊的律师米歇尔·威尔金森-史密斯（Michelle Wilkinson Smith），他此前被无罪释放，面临谋杀两个双胞胎儿子的指控。以下是侦探督察约翰·蒂姆斯（John Timms）在裁决后所说的话：我认为这很重要，并且我认为需要明确传达这样一个信息，即在那个周末出现在考特尼
Crescent over that weekend was considered a person of interest and we thoroughly investigated each person until we identified Chris Kahui and then made the arrest there are no leads that we could follow up as I've said there is no evidence to support a charge against any other person and that includes the mother Maxina King I think we should all remember that the last two years has been about Chris and crew Kahui the twins and nobody else and that has not changed for the result today this has been a tough investigation a tough trial it's been a tough two years but what I would say is that with any child death
新月街（Courtney Crescent）的每个人都被视为利益相关者，我们对每个人进行了彻底调查，直到确定了克里斯·卡胡伊，然后实施了逮捕。正如我所说，没有任何我们可以跟进的线索，没有证据支持对任何其他人提出指控，这包括母亲马克西娜·金（Maxina King）。我认为我们都应该记住，过去两年里，焦点一直是克里斯和克鲁·卡胡伊（Krui Kahui）这对双胞胎，没有别人，这一事实并没有随着今天的裁决而改变。这是一次艰难的调查，一次艰难的审判，这是艰难的两年，但我要说的是，对于任何儿童死亡案件，
those involved with the witnesses or offenders are normally related to the dead child with this comes the problem that the family have loyalties to each other not always to the dead child so that was it from the police perspective all the evidence pointed to Chris Kahui nobody else but the jury acquitted him in record time there was nothing more they could do there was a newspaper article released shortly after the trial which was pretty concerning actually I'd say it's disturbing the article outlined that the trial was put at risk when a juror on the case was at the pub with his friends and told them several members of the jury had already said they didn't think Chris had killed his twins
那些涉案的证人或肇事者通常与死去的孩子有亲属关系。随之而来的问题是，家庭成员彼此之间存在忠诚度，而不是总是对死去的孩子忠诚。所以，这就是警方的看法，所有的证据都指向克里斯·卡胡伊，没有别人，但陪审团以创纪录的速度宣告他无罪。他们已经无能为力了。在审判结束后不久，有一篇报纸文章发表，实际上相当令人担忧，我想说这是令人不安的。文章概述说，当本案的一名陪审团成员和朋友在酒吧时，告诉他们陪审团的几名成员已经表示他们认为克里斯没有杀死他的双胞胎，从而使审判面临风险。
this was said after the first days of what was a six-week trial so much for carefully considering all the evidence before coming to a decision word eventually got back to the prosecutors and judge about this but all that came of it was the judge warning the jury they had to consider all the evidence before reaching a verdict some law experts commented that it could have been grounds for a mistrial after being acquitted of murder Chris became the father of a baby girl to a different partner initially he was forced to live separate from his new partner and daughter but he was allowed to move in two years later in 2010
这是在长达六周的审判的第一天之后说的。在做出决定之前仔细考虑所有证据简直是个笑话。检察官和法官最终获悉了此事，但结果只是法官警告陪审团，他们在做出裁决前必须考虑所有证据。一些法律专家评论说，这本可以成为宣布审判无效的理由。在被宣告谋杀无罪后，克里斯与另一位伴侣生了一个女婴。最初，他被迫与他的新伴侣和女儿分开居住，但两年后的2010年，他被允许搬进去。
however even then he wasn't allowed to be alone with his daughter as of 2012 he still had to be supervised at all times with her child services were closely monitoring on the 4th of October 2010 a coronial inquest into the twins death commenced held before coroner Gary Evans Chris had the right to silence at his criminal trial but not so at the coronial inquest and by now Chris's stories had changed his version of what happened when crew stopped breathing was one of the parts of
然而，即便在那时，他也不被允许单独和女儿在一起。截至2012年，他与她在一起时仍必须随时接受监督。儿童服务机构对此进行了密切监测。2010年10月4日，针对双胞胎死因的验尸研讯正式开始，由验尸官加里·埃文斯（Gary Evans）主持。克里斯在刑事审判中有权保持沉默，但在验尸研讯中则不然。到此时，克里斯的说法已经改变了。关于克鲁停止呼吸时发生了什么的说法，是他的说辞中的一部分
his story that was now different at the inquest that changed a couple of times actually he first said he gave crew CPR and he came right he later said he went to perform CPR but he didn't have to because he came right and started breathing before he did anything but later still in the inquest he went back to his original CPR story again he testified that he was freaking out really afraid and thought crew was dying but instead of calling an ambulance and getting medical help he outlined how he sent his sister and his dad to find Maxina
现在在研讯中有了不同。实际上，这种说法已经变了好几次。他首先说他给克鲁做了心肺复苏（CPR），克鲁就恢复正常了。他后来改口说他去做了心肺复苏，但他不必这么做，因为在他在做任何事情之前，克鲁就恢复正常并开始呼吸了。但在研讯中更晚的时候，他又回到了最初的心肺复苏的说法。他作证说，他当时吓坏了，非常害怕，以为克鲁快死了，但由于没有叫救护车并获得医疗帮助，他讲述了他是如何派他的姐姐和爸爸去寻找马克西娜的。
he was asked by the coroner that if he had a puppy and stopped breathing would he call a vet Chris said yes he would when the coroner then asked why didn't you call an ambulance or take crew to the hospital when he stopped breathing Chris couldn't offer an explanation Chris also testified that he now realized how important it was to establish when the twins were last fed and appeared healthy he said looking back the twins didn't feed when they usually would have after Maxina left he said he doesn't think baby Chris cried or fed at all after Maxina left
验尸官问他，如果他有一只小狗停止呼吸，他会叫兽医吗？克里斯说他会的。当验尸官接着问为什么克鲁停止呼吸时你不叫救护车或送他去医院，克里斯无法解释。克里斯还作证说，他现在意识到确定双胞胎最后一次喂食且看起来健康的时间是多么重要。他说，回想起来，在马克西娜离开后，双胞胎没有像平时那样进食。他说他认为小克里斯在马克西娜离开后根本没有哭也没有吃东西，
but he couldn't say the same about crew as there was April's testimony she fed him but it was clear what he was trying to do make it seem like Maxina could have injured them before she left he now realized how important the timings were all right and he was changing the story but the three statements he gave to police were done one before and two soon after the twins death which was now four years ago in these statements he said that he had fed them numerous times after Maxina had left when asked the reason for his change in his story Chris's defense claimed he hadn't told the truth to the police because he was a simple boy and he didn't want the police to think he was a bad father by not having fed the twins that night
但他对克鲁不能这么说，因为有四月的证词：她喂了他，但很明显他试图做的是：让大家觉得马克西娜可能在离开前伤害了他们。他现在意识到时间点是多么重要，好吧，他在改变说法，但他向警方做出的三份陈述中，一份是在双胞胎死前，两份是在双胞胎死后不久，这已经是四年前的事了。在这些陈述中，他说马克西娜离开后他喂了他们好多次。当被问及改变说法的理由时，克里斯的辩护方声称他没有对警方说实话，因为他是一个单纯的男孩，他不想让警方认为他是一个糟糕的父亲，因为那天晚上没有喂双胞胎
at all the coroner wasn't buying it and Chris himself conceded in cross-examination what he said in his police interviews four years earlier would have been his best recollection of what had occurred not now the coroner asked Chris about his time alone in the room with the twins just prior to when Cruz stopped breathing the coroner asked him what was he doing in there Chris replied I think I was picking up stuff off the ground the coroner said it wouldn't take three minutes to pick up stuff would it Chris said no the coroner said so what else were you doing Chris said I can't remember what I was doing in there the coroner found that Chris's behavior was consistent with trying to avoid medical authorities as he knew the twins were in a bad way he was scathing
根本没有喂。验尸官并不买账，克里斯自己在盘问中承认，他四年前在警方采访中所说的话将是他对所发生事情的最深刻记忆，而不是现在。验尸官问克里斯，在克鲁停止呼吸前不久，他独自和双胞胎在房间里的时间在做什么。验尸官问他在里面做什么。克里斯回答说：我想我是在地上捡东西。验尸官说：捡东西不需要三分钟吧？克里斯说：不需要。验尸官说：那你在做什么？克里斯说：我不记得我在里面做什么了。验尸官发现克里斯的行为与试图避开医疗机构是一致的，因为他知道双胞胎情况糟糕。他进行了严厉的批评，
he said the behavior of Chris Cahoui in turning his back on the pressing needs of his sons for medical attention straight away is incompatible with that of a normal father whose only concerns are his children's welfare this bugged telephone call recorded by police between Chris and his father Banjo doesn't paint a great picture Chris is recorded as saying see fuck if we never went into the hospital that time we went to the doctors fucking they probably never would have found out but Banjo said who Chris said the police when they ain't even you know if we never had checked up on anything and then we still probably you know if the boys you know the coroner also asked Chris about the period of time when Maxina first presented the twins to
他说，克里斯·卡胡伊（Chris Kahui）对儿子需要立即医疗救助的迫切需求置之不理的行为，与一个唯一的担忧就是孩子福祉的正常父亲的行为是不相容的。这段由警方记录的克里斯和他的父亲班杰（Banjo）之间被窃听的电话，并没有描绘出一幅美好的画面。据记录，克里斯说：看他妈的，如果那次我们没去医院，我们去看医生那次，他妈的他们可能永远不会发现。但班杰说：谁？克里斯说：警察。当他们甚至你知道，如果我们从未对任何事情进行过检查，那么我们可能仍然你知道，如果孩子们你知道。验尸官还询问了克里斯关于马克西娜最初将双胞胎送到
the hospital when she tried repeatedly to call him and get him up there but he was too busy with the playstation the coroner asked was she worried about the twins health Chris said yes she was coroner and she wanted you to come to the hospital to be with her Chris yes coroner because you were the father Chris yes coroner well why did you not go Chris I did not really want to be walking up to the hospital coroner you did not really want to be walking up to the hospital Chris yes I would have rather her come to pick me up never mind the twins condition at the time and Maxina was up there freaking out
医院的那段时间，她多次打电话让他去那里，但他一直在玩PlayStation游戏机太忙了。验尸官问：她担心双胞胎的健康吗？克里斯说：是的，她担心。验尸官：她希望你来医院陪她吗？克里斯：是的。验尸官：因为你是父亲吗？克里斯：是的。验尸官：那为什么不去？克里斯：我其实不想走到医院去。验尸官：你其实不想走到医院去？克里斯：是的，我宁愿她来接我。完全不管当时双胞胎的情况，而马克西娜在那里吓坏了，
never mind there was another car that was in the driveway that he could have taken and never mind that the hospital actually wasn't that far away and was well within walking distance the coroner was satisfied that the injuries suffered by the twins that led to their death were non-accidental in nature the cause of death was the result of the application of force at the hands of another or others and that more than likely their injuries were inflicted at the same time by the same person he found that Chris Cahoui knew something was wrong when the twins ceased to cry out to be fed and he knew they were obviously unwell for reasons of his own he neglected to summon medical help they urgently needed he found cell phone records corroborated Maxina King's
不管车道上还有另一辆他可以开的车，也不管医院其实离得并不远，完全在步行可到达的范围内。验尸官确信导致双胞胎死亡的伤势并非意外造成。死因是在他人或多人的武力作用下造成的，而且他们的伤势更有可能是由同一个人在同一时间造成的。他发现克里斯·卡胡伊知道当双胞胎不再哭喊着要吃东西时出了问题，而且他知道他们明显不舒服。由于他自己的原因，他没有叫来他们迫切需要的医疗帮助。他发现手机记录证实了马克西娜·金的
story of her whereabouts on the night he found it implausible and in direct contradiction to a lot of other evidence that Maxina could have returned home and injured the twins in fact he said there wasn't a scaric of evidence to suggest that Maxina had anything to do with their injuries once all of the evidence had been presented at the coronal inquest everyone eagerly awaited the coroner's official ruling a coroner has found the violent deaths of the Cahoui twins happened while they were in the sole care of their father Chris Cahoui the three-month old twins Chris and crew died of head injuries in 2006 Chris Cahoui was found not guilty of killing the babies after a five-week criminal trial in the high court at Auckland in 2008
关于她那天晚上行踪的说法。他认为马克西娜可能回家并伤害了双胞胎的说法是难以置信的，并且与许多其他证据直接矛盾。事实上，他说没有任何一丝证据表明马克西娜与他们的伤势有任何关系。一旦在验尸研讯中出示了所有证据，每个人都热切等待验尸官的官方裁决。验尸官发现卡胡伊双胞胎的暴力死亡发生在他们仅由其父亲克里斯·卡胡伊照顾期间。这对三个月大的双胞胎克里斯和克鲁于2006年死于头部受伤。克里斯·卡胡伊在奥克兰高等法院2008年长达五周的刑事审判后被判杀害婴儿罪名不成立。
the coroner's inquest into the deaths of the twins began in October 2010 and were completed in June last year in a report published this morning the coroner Gary Evans says the twins died from brain injuries suffered while they were in the sole custody care and control of Chris Cahoui at their South Auckland home he says the twins were injured in the same manner at the same time and at the hands of the same person the coroner dismissed claims the twins could have been injured by their mother Maxina King or by her brother Stuart King well our reporter Sam Mora joins Sam the coroner here basically is establishing the facts of what happened that's right Simon the the coroner finds that both Chris and crew died in hospital on June the 18th 2006 now this was as
对双胞胎死因的验尸研讯于2010年10月开始，并于去年6月结束。在今天上午发布的报告中，验尸官加里·埃文斯（Gary Evans）表示，双胞胎死于在南奥克兰家中由克里斯·卡胡伊独家监护、照顾和控制期间遭受的脑损伤。他说，双胞胎在同一时间以相同的方式受伤，且出自同一人之手。验尸官驳回了双胞胎可能被其母亲马克西娜·金或其舅舅斯图尔特·金（Stuart King）伤害的说法。我们的记者萨姆·莫拉（Sam Mora）加入了我们。萨姆，验尸官这里基本上是在确定事情真相？没错，西蒙，验尸官发现克里斯和克鲁都在2006年6月18日死于医院，而这是作为
a result of injuries that happened when they were in the care of their father Chris Cahoui now the 77 page report says Chris Cahoui was resentful of the fact he'd been left by his partner Maxina King to care for the twins in fact it says that he was angered by her absence for the second night in a row the evening the injuries were inflicted on the babies that is June the 12th now the coroner says the twins were in every respect normal and well at 1 p.m on June the 12th but that there was no evidence that their father fed them that afternoon or evening or the next morning the report says he hid the fact the twins were not crying or eating and were unwell and the coroner says that keeping this from the twins mother and the others in the house is incompatible with the
他们由父亲克里斯·卡胡伊照顾时发生受伤的结果。这份77页的报告称，克里斯·卡胡伊对被伴侣马克西娜·金留下照顾双胞胎一事感到不满。事实上，报告称，在婴儿受伤害的当晚（即6月12日），对于她连续第二个晚上不在家，他感到愤怒。现在验尸官说，在6月12日下午1点，双胞胎在各方面都正常且健康，但没有证据表明他们的父亲那天下午或晚上或第二天早上喂过他们。报告称，他隐瞒了双胞胎没有哭、没有吃东西且身体不适的事实，并且验尸官说，对双胞胎的母亲和家中的其他人隐瞒这一点是不符合
behavior one would reasonably expect from a normal father who had nothing to hide concerning his children's condition now the report says that the fact the twins were not feeding was vitally important information which he kept to himself and it says after the time one of the twins crew stopped breathing Mr Cahoui resisted the views of other adults that an ambulance should be called or the twins should be taken to hospital fundamentally the coroner says had they been taken to hospital their lives might have been saved and of course we know the babies weren't taken to hospital until the following day so what is the evidence this finding is based on well the coroner gives a detailed account of what happened in June 2006 he outlines a list of things Mr Cahoui has said both
人们对一个对孩子状况无可隐瞒的正常父亲所合理期望的行为。报告称，双胞胎没有进食这一事实是至关重要的情况，但他却将其秘而不宣。报告还说，在其中一个双胞胎克鲁停止呼吸后，卡胡伊先生抗拒其他成年人提出的应该叫救护车或把双胞胎送往医院的意见。从根本上说，验尸官表示，如果他们被送到医院，他们的生命可能就会得救。当然，我们知道婴儿直到第二天下午才被送往医院。那么，这一裁决基于什么证据呢？验尸官详细叙述了2006年6月发生的事情，他列出了卡胡伊先生所说的一系列事情，无论是在
in court and during various interviews with the police and other authorities but he says there is no evidence to support these statements he points out that Chris Cahoui made a fundamental change to his evidence at the inquest into his son's deaths that is that the twins did not cry or feed again after midday on June the 12th and this contradicts the evidence given in his three earlier police statements that the twins had been fed by him again later that day now the coroner says it's likely the false account given by Mr Cahoui was to protect himself by representing that the twins remained well whilst in his hands and he says he found Chris Cahoui's evidence seriously conflicting in nature lacking in credibility and not to be relied upon and Sam what does the
法庭上还是在接受警方和其他当局的各种采访时。但他说，没有证据支持这些陈述。他指出，克里斯·卡胡伊在关于他儿子死亡的研讯中对其证据做出了根本性的改变，即双胞胎在6月12日中午之后再也没有哭过或吃过东西，这与他此前三份警方陈述中的证据相矛盾，即双胞胎那天晚些时候曾被他再次喂食。验尸官表示，卡胡伊先生给出虚假陈述可能是为了保护自己，宣称双胞胎在他手中时依然保持健康。他说，他发现克里斯·卡胡伊的证据在性质上严重矛盾、缺乏可信度且不可信赖。萨姆，那么
coroner say about the earlier criminal proceedings Simon the coroner's court is only concerned with questions of fact questions relating to criminal responsibility have already been tried out and disposed of by the High Court but the question of how the twins came to meet their death is quite different to whether Mr Cahoui bears any responsibility in terms of the criminal's law for their deaths and of course he has been found to bear no such responsibility but the purpose of the coroner's report is to identify the causes and circumstances of the twins' death and again that finding is that the twins died from brain injury suffered while in the sole custody care and control of Chris Cahoui and as you mentioned earlier the coroner also dismisses the
验尸官对早些时候的刑事诉讼程序怎么说？西蒙，验尸官法庭只关乎事实问题，与刑事责任有关的问题已经由高等法院审理并作了处理。但是，双胞胎如何走向死亡的问题与卡胡伊先生是否对他们的死承担任何刑法意义上的责任是完全不同的。当然，他被认定不承担此类责任。但验尸官报告的目的是查明双胞胎死因和环境，再次强调，这一裁决是双胞胎死于在克里斯·卡胡伊独家监护、照顾和控制期间遭受的脑损伤。正如你刚才提到的，验尸官还驳回了
claims the twins could have been killed by their mother Maxina King or her brother Stuart King the coroner says there is not a scaric of evidence that Maxina King was at home at the time of the injuries the time the injuries happened let alone that she had a motive to kill her own children and did so and likewise the coroner says there is not a scantilla of evidence to support the allegation that Stuart King hurt the twins and what response has there been to the coroner's findings from Chris Cahoui well Mr Cahoui and his legal representatives have declined to comment on the findings but they have issued a statement in which Mr Cahoui again denies any involvement in the twins' deaths and strongly rejects the coroner's findings and what about the police what
双胞胎可能被他们的母亲马克西娜·金或她的兄弟斯图尔特·金杀害的说法。验尸官说，没有任何一丝证据表明马克西娜·金在伤害发生时在家，更不用说她有杀害自己孩子并付诸实施的动机了。同样，验尸官说，没有任何微小的证据支持斯图尔特·金伤害双胞胎的指控。那么克里斯·卡胡伊对验尸官的裁决有什么回应呢？卡胡伊先生和他的法律代表拒绝就裁决发表评论，但他们发表了一份声明，卡胡伊先生在声明中再次否认参与双胞胎的死亡，并强烈拒绝验尸官的裁决。那么警方呢？
have they got to say the police have also declined to comment but they too have issued a statement in which they say they thoroughly investigated the deaths of the Cahoui twins and put all available evidence before the court for examination and judgment the police say they're still considering the evidence heard during the coroner's inquests and they will not be making any further comment until that analysis is completed thank you Sam that's our reporter Sam Morrow joining me in the studio now you're wondering given the result of the coronal inquest did the police lay fresh charges against Chris Cahoui well he's your answer the police in South Auckland say they will not be laying further charges over the deaths of the Cahoui twins the twins died in 2006 and a trial
他们有什么要说的？警方也拒绝置评，但他们也发表了一份声明，称他们彻底调查了卡胡伊双胞胎的死因，并将所有可用的证据提交给法庭进行审查和判决。警方表示，他们仍在考虑在验尸研讯期间听取的证据，在该分析完成之前，他们不会作进一步评论。谢谢你，萨姆。我们的记者萨姆·莫拉在演播室加入了我。你可能会想，鉴于验尸研讯的结果，警方是否会对克里斯·卡胡伊提出新的指控？答案在这里。南奥克兰警方表示，他们不会就卡胡伊双胞胎的死因提出进一步指控。这对双胞胎于2006年死亡，而一场
in 2008 cleared their father Chris Cahoui of their murder but the police have been reviewing the evidence since a coroner's report in July this year said the babies died while in the sole care of their father the police have declined to be interviewed but Chris Cahoui's lawyer Lorraine Smith joins us now good morning good morning Simon what does this decision mean for your client it means the end of the um the the criminal trial process um Simon I'm not at all surprised at the decision that was released yesterday um Superintendent Tim said that following a review of the evidence that the coroner's inquest no further charges will be laid um I was in Israel during the inquest but I understand that no substantially different evidence from that given that the criminal trial
2008年的审判清除了他们父亲克里斯·卡胡伊的谋杀罪名，但自今年7月一份验尸官报告称婴儿在仅由其父亲照顾期间死亡以来，警方一直在审查证据。警方拒绝接受采访，但克里斯·卡胡伊的律师洛林·史密斯（Lorraine Smith）现在加入了我们。早上好。早上好，西蒙。这个决定对你的当事人意味着什么？这意味着刑事审判程序的结束。西蒙，我对昨天发布的决定一点也不感到意外。蒂姆斯总警司表示，在对验尸研讯的证据进行审查后，将不会提出进一步指控。我在研讯期间在以色列，但我了解到，并没有提出与刑事审判时
was advanced and the coroner's hearing um talk I understand about three weeks whereas the jury trial heard evidence over seven weeks it was presided over by a judge of the high court and um the jury included a medical doctor who was familiar with the issues of bleeding on bleeding on the brain I mean we had a smart jury and Lorraine Smith nevertheless the public has heard what the coroner's got to say surely there's a a cloud hanging over your client's head because of the coroner's view not at all in my view there is absolutely no comparison between a coroner's and inquiry in a high court jury trial uh and as I said I'm not at all surprised by this decision but the uh the jury as you mentioned the jury the jury decides on evidence put before it uh the
实质上不同的证据。验尸官听证会进行了大约三周，而陪审团审判听取了七周的证据，由高等法院法官主持，并且陪审团包括一名熟悉脑出血问题的医学医生。我的意思是，我们有一个聪明的陪审团。洛林·史密斯，尽管如此，公众已经听到了验尸官的说法，因为验尸官的观点，你的当事人头顶上肯定悬着一朵阴云吧？一点也不。在我看来，验尸官调查和高等法院陪审团审判之间绝对没有可比性。正如我所说，我对这个决定一点也不感到意外。但是正如你提到的陪审团，陪审团根据提交给它的证据做出决定，而
coroner coroner can take a broader view can't he he's not meeting the standard of a criminal standard of proof uh but well he heard exactly the same evidence he relitigated um the the the trial and while we're on that topic I have no doubt that our judges are going to be very concerned about relitigation of cases by the coroner um relitigation undermines the integrity of jury verdict he's doing his job isn't he pardon he's just doing his job I think he went down the wrong track frankly and if I'd been in New Zealand I would I would have um pointed this out to him um what what it means is that if the police aren't happy with a jury verdict they can have another go on the in the coroner's court um and and that's just not right and I think you'll find that the
验尸官可以采取更广泛的视角，不是吗？他没有达到刑事证明标准。但他听取了完全相同的证据，重新审理了审判。正当我们谈到这个话题时，我毫不怀疑我们的法官将非常关切验尸官对案件的重新审理。重新审理破坏了陪审团裁决的完整性。他在做他的工作，不是吗？抱歉？他只是在做他的工作。坦率地说，我认为他走错了方向。如果我在新西兰，我会向他指出这一点。这意味着，如果警方对陪审团的裁决不满意，他们可以在验尸官法庭再试一次，这是不对的。我想你会发现，
judges especially in the high court are extremely concerned about this aspect but nevertheless Lorraine Smith many in the public might have read the the coroner's report and think your clients to be blunt still did it and many of them will have followed the jury trial which was seven weeks not three and come to the conclusion that the jury got it right the police do say the case remains open and if there is new information that comes to hand they'll look at it I mean would it be in your client's interest to try and find new information well how can he I mean he did his best um to you know to to tell the police everything that he knew both when he was interviewed over a period of many many hours um before the trial and when he gave evidence uh at the the
法官，特别是在高等法院的法官，对这一方面极其关切。尽管如此，洛林·史密斯，许多公众可能读了验尸官的报告，并认为坦率地说你的当事人还是做了这件事，并且他们中的许多人会关注那场为期七周而非三周的陪审团审判，并得出结论认为陪审团做出了正确的判断。警方确实表示该案仍然悬而未决，如果有新信息出现，他们会进行调查。我的意思是，设法寻找新信息符合你当事人的利益吗？好吧，他怎么能呢？我的意思是，他尽了最大努力向警方讲述他所知道的一切，无论是在审判前历时许多小时的讯问中，还是在
inquest um this is going to remain a cold case it's never going to go away until the person who killed the twins is found There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
研讯中作证。这将仍然是一起悬案，在找到杀死双胞胎的人之前，它永远不会消失。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。